Display an Freakshow.
Sag mir wie ich ein Pfannkuchen mach und dann spiel Beatles.
Ich kann dir helfen Bäckereien zu finden wenn du die Ortungsdienste aktivierst hörspielmusik mein Musikgeschmack ist eher außergewöhnlich ich glaube nicht dass dir der gefällt.
Die Radio ist ganz bestimmt unbestimmt.
Music.
Am Start hallo jetzt die Freakshow.
Nummer 214 vom 14 März 2018.
Was auch immer das bedeuten mag so ein kurzes Echo Studio ausmachen jetzt gut ehrlich ja das war so für Feinheiten so wahrnehmen muss ne.
Das nach all den Jahren dieses Rauschen und das Knistern weg soviel schon da Besetzung mit Letizia.
Tach tach und meiner einer der Typen genau ja.
Und jetzt sind 15 unsere Themen am Ende festgestellt,
nur weil es hätte mich überquillt also wir können Topf noch auskratzen und was ist der arbeit zugegebenermaßen wenn es auf eine Bildschirmseite passt.
Also dass sie so dumm Überlänge,
also wir haben ja letzte Mal schon hier Backstage darüber sinniert ob wir denn auf so ein Podcast Trend aufspringen sollen.
Und diese Frage fragt uns doch was Nummer mal fahren sollen.
Aber sicher mal wieder vergessen.
Liebe höre na ja das ist jetzt der Stream mehr wert ne.
Das primärwert wer wäre das jetzt live hört hat die Chance noch eine Frage zu stellen er ist müssen wir es bloß sagen drauf einigen was der Kanal ist.
Keine E-Mails kein Telefon das Fenster auf also wenn wir jetzt sagen Twitter dann dann explodiert deine Inbox.
Na dann sehe ich das vorallem erstmal nur weil ihr da ja nicht mitlesen wenn man sagen schlägt dann ist es so tanken auf den Fleck beschränkt aus der vielleicht auch nicht so schlecht.
Wie markiert man das mit einem sehr interessanten Problem wie man die.
Das coole war aktiver arbeiten wie soll unterstützen kann nein,
immer das kollaborative Arbeit unterstützen kann als ich in Rostock studiert habe gehabt so eine Vorlesungsreihe,
aktuelle Forschungsschwerpunkte in der Visualisierung und visual Analytics und ein sehr beliebtes Thema war in der Tat,
was wir hin fährt bis Plätze haben oder in dem Fall wir gucken auf das Beamerbild hier in der Metaebene,
wieder wie man mit mehreren Leuten an so einem System arbeiten kann unsere Use Case wann wir wollen zusammen Urlaub planen oder wie jetzt wir wollen eine Sendung Plan dass man so fensterbach,
Fenster rüberziehen kann in den gemeinsam genutzten Bereich und dann Sachen auch markieren und Highlighten kann.
Ich habe da leider nie wieder Sachen darüber gehört.
Müsste ich mal recherchieren weil das ist ja ein Thema was immer wieder auf kommt also gerade so im so Studio Situation wahrscheinlich ja ja Google Docs ist nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss oder Sony sapad.
Nee das alles Elend Tod und Verderben.
Google Wave.
Also.
Camel auch schon viele Gedanken zu gemacht man grundsätzlich so einen Chat hat schon mal den Vorteil da können und wie auch alle mit umgehen und sind auch mehr oder weniger gleichberechtigt dran ne und so shared Whiteboards gibt's ja durchaus,
na bloß was was machst du denn dann mit deinem voicebase rum malen irgendwo was drauf schreiben so,
also ich kapiere das nicht hier sag mal kurz wir warten ich hatte neulich einen,
habe ich mich mal etwas ausführlicher so zu meiner ganzen Vergangenheit geäußert beim Sendungsbewusstsein Sendungsbewusstsein fundinfo vor 1 2 3 Ausgaben.
Die stimmt überhaupt nicht doch da war ich auch mal nicht meine was ganz anderem an den sendegarten Entschuldigung sende Garten sind im Garten bitte das,
ZDF Fernsehgarten Bilder davon mag es auch unter anderem beeinflusst sein das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau,
deine Karte ist ein sehr schönes Format wer von euch das noch nicht kennen kann er auch vielleicht mal reinhören es ist so so inside Baseball der der deutschen Podcasting 10 oder Zwist eines Teils der der deutschen Podcasting Zählernummer.
Destine saurma der ich mich auch selber so ein bisschen angeschlossen fühle weil er einfach viele Leute agieren die ich kenne aber auch immer wieder neue Leute mit reingebracht werden die ich auch noch nicht kenne,
und das ganze ist so eine Art Magazin, sagen falls es findet und wie alle zwei Wochen Start und ist so.
Neuigkeiten so was ist so passiert neue Podcast Lotte empfehlen Sendung diskutieren aber auch sozusagen Formate und üblicherweise ist auch immer pro Sendung nimmt Gas da das sind,
darf ich zu 90% dann Podcast Asia selber irgendwie was machen was gestartet haben schon lange dabei sind etc,
wo das immer sehr ausführlich geht so drei Stunden oder so und ja es ist eine ist eine schöne,
Quelle auch immer Neues kennenzulernen aber auch die Interviews die Kollektiv geführt werden vor allem macht das der Martin.
Rücklader Brigitte auf jeden Fall am meisten einen macht es auch sehr schön und da kommt da kommt eine Menge bei Robert oder Meister und wie auch mal da habe ich halt diese ganze Story noch mal mit der,
Villa erzähl das hat mir ja schon paar mal und das war dann auch etwas detaillierter alles und da kam dann auch das Gespräch auf,
was hat zu dieser Zeit auch stattfand auf ein anderes Projekt das hieß Piazza virtuale.
Na wir reden halt jetzt hier von 93 ungefähr.
Und was 94 das war nämlich anlässlich der documenta dass wir mal gucken wann die documenta da genau.
War.
Unfall zum Kunstprojekt und digitales Niederlande wieso Satellitenfernsehen legen und haben dann quasi darüber einen Bild für alle gemacht und das war ja auch alles noch so Pre.
Pre web on Hop off Pre Internet und,
das war insofern so kollaborativ als das da auch im wieso Chat Elemente gab und Leute konnten halt irgendwie anrufen und Dinge sagen also auch für dieser Versuch alles so auf einem Screen zusammen laufen sodass Sie bitte sich nicht als Kollaboration bezeichnen also vielleicht so eine kollaboratives,
Entertainment so aber eben one screen.
Und von daher war das eigentlich ganz ganz spannend documenta 9 wann das E92 genau das muss das gewesen sein.
Ja und Puls.
Also ich weiß dass in diesem education Bereich sind halt so allerlei also richtig was durchgesetzt hat sich dazu dann da da würde ich noch nicht ne und geradezu für so eine Livesendung wäre das in der Tat ganz,
ganz brauchbar.
Warum einfach so ein interaktives video irgendwie zu betreiben so ne Leute werfen Content rein z.b.
Leute werfen Content Rainer weißt du gleich ja das können wir sein,
und dann ich habe dir mal die URL im Chat geschickt und dann mache ich die mal auf und Webbrowser und so und dann muss das an Mischpult angeschlossen sein es ist irgendwie alles ein bisschen awkward und schwierig und wo ist dann das Fenster und kommt da was bei raus und,
verschiedene.
Nordfranz auch mal wieder so willst nicht mal was mit Video machen und nach dem Motto YouTube oder sowas immer sagen Sony wie lange müssen frische vom vom Leib weil ich einfach diese talking head Formate so überhaupt nicht reizvoll finde.
Nichtsdestotrotz wäre Sohn YouTube dem Youtuber Petterson Tim Pritlove ganz gut glaube ich warum.
Wäre so anguckt wenn sich da sonst so dumm ist ja gut die Frage ist ja nicht was würde YouTube guttun oder was tut mir gut.
Okay also frei ist würde mir YouTube gut tun so und das na ja.
Eisemann Zweifel nichtsdestotrotz finde ich den Gedanken quasi zu seiner Live-Sendung auch noch ein Videokanal zu haben.
Also z.b. als Stream natürlich ne weil rum Satellitenfernsehen kann aber jetzt nicht immer unbedingt über das halt die Frage was was sieht man dann da drauf und das will ich doch auch mal probiert.
Hatten die doch werden irgendwie so ein sondern Desktop hatten wir da gestreamt wo wir dann ab und zu mal links aufgemacht haben und so weiter doch hatten wir das mal gemacht das haben wir mal gemacht ja.
Clemens damals irgendwie der hatte das.
Da irgend so ein Mac mini irgendwo da so und da lief der ganze Kram drauf und das hatten wir dann gestreamt.
Ja ja gut aber das aber wieder Ballett ist Frage des topstream ist halt irgendwie die leben.
Ja wisst nicht Leuten dabei zuschauen wie sie irgendwie Browserfenster mit der Maus auf dem Bildschirm platzieren sollen das ganze muss halt irgendwie so ein ausbildungskanal sein die man halt einfach leichte füttern kann wo man irgendwie auch so ein,
Command & control Interface hard sowie Jamies ich eben nur sagen kann okay Bling hier was ich gucke sagt dieses Video,
dann taucht das bei mir so in so einer Innenbox Liste auf und dann will ich das irgendwie mit einer Tasse aus und dann ist das,
so jetzt das Video was dann erstmal so Picture-in-Picture mäßig spielt aber dann eben auch über geblendet werden kann auf Fullscreen ist ja das hat alles mit mehr oder weniger softwarebasiert einen Chat Kanal so eine Anwendung irgendwie Soundfiles sowas,
dass du das was du dir so.
Ich habe gerade auch in der Tat mal in meinen Vorlesungsfolien auf dem Rechner gesucht und es rausgefunden wie das ist hieß kollaborativ in vollem Gang,
ich schaue mal ob ich dazu das research paper finde wenn ich fand den Ansatz.
Damals doch sehr spannend also der Claim der da vor allem auch war es war nicht nur so dieses reisen sondern was ist wenn interdisziplinär gearbeitet wird so Pathologe Biologe Genetiker,
das sollst du aus verschiedenen Bereichen.
Wieso einen virtuellen Raum dann halt auch schon so schaffen kannst du so ich weiß nicht also ich fand das sehr sehr spannend weil es war natürlich sehr stark auch die der Fokus auf Visualisierung gelegt.
Aber so als Beispiel wenn man so stell ich mal so mehrere Fenster nebeneinander vor dir so mit Hexen vergleicht dass du manchmal ein Wort in einem.
Text geheiratet wird und über alle Fenster hinweg mit einem mit so einem Link im Sinne von ich ziehe Pantanal gesagt eine Linie darüber und,
Highlighter die gesamten Wörter.
Auf deiner auf deinem Bildschirm also das fand ich schon sehr sehr spannend oder wenn es sogar mehr kann als nur Highlighten von Wörtern an die Stellen springen die die Bedeutung des Wortes haben,
also das dann um,
Mittagessen Netzplan oder sowas zu sehen das ist ein wirklich an die Stelle springen wo dieses Wort also dieser dieser Gegenstand dann auf Tauris ist er sehr interessant.
Und ja das kann man ja auch eben nicht nur mit Bild oder Texten wie in dem Fall machen sondern auch einfach mit mehreren Medien.
Wie heißt das Nummer Caritas in folienking.
Das sind sehr generischer Begriff da kommst du ja auf allerlei,
seit über nicht lesen will also was du da gerade beschrieben hast klang so ein bisschen wie so ein also für mich klang es so nach einem neuen Open-Source-Projekt was da was du da startest,
ich hatte schon Namen Wettlauf,
das greift mir zu kurz also wahrscheinlich gibt's sicherlich irgendwie Systeme mit dem man das bauen kann.
Die allerdings noch sehr viel so Videotechnik erfordern nur mit HDMI Quellen umschalten und sowas.
Na ja so wie soll ich sagen was ich nicht Widersacher Ernst AirPlay senken würden ja auch reichen.
Nein nein nein nein nein aber nicht.
Erzählt ne das ist ja nur fern abspielen willst du Endkontrolle sein willst ja irgendwie dann Flo machen willst das Bild muss halt entertaining sein und das ist halt einfach schwierig insbesondere man nebenbei halt ein ich noch eine Radiosendung machen aber irgendwie so ein definierter Kanal Zeit braucht man einfach jemand der sieht einfach ausschließlich darum kümmert aber das,
ist auch nicht ja.
So schwer kanns nicht sein heißt das im Chat na ja nur das YouTube also halt nicht arbeiten sonst mal das sieht man diesen Videos ja auch an,
die schnippeln der Visionäre wie die Bekloppten deswegen ist es auch alles so und so ein so ein so ein so ein hektisches Zeug.
Ja und wenn sie meine Live-Sendung machen dann stehen sie irgendwo eine Kamera hin.
Was ist das ist das weil ich irgendwie alt bin dass dass mich das so nervt kann man kann man kann man diese.
Diese hibbeligkeit irgendwie so inhalieren das anders und wir auf einmal gar nichts mehr ausmacht oder hat das irgendwie lassen Videos.
Also weil den Leuten den ich so folge ich weiß was du meinst,
also es gibt es gibt diesen diesen Youtuber Style möglichst viele Pausen raus zu schneiden manche sind schon soweit dass sie so so hektisch reden oder dem,
die Sprache so hektisch zusammenschneiden dass sie im Hintergrund das was sie sagen nochmals text,
haben damit man eine Chance hat zu verstehen was sie erzählen das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Was gibt's in allen beliebigen Steigerungsform.
Ja dann gibt's wieder die Leute die es nicht mehr schaffen der Kamera irgendwie ruhig zu halten und vor allen Dingen auf dem auf das Objekt zu richten was man gerade sehen will,
na ja meine sei nicht dass es nicht nicht auch interessanten Content gibt ne gerade zu Hause also etwas seriöser Inhalte wenn Leute versuchen darf Wissenschaft zu erklären etc dann sind das ja alles,
bitte Sachen und da ist sicherlich viel Format Werdum.
Am laufen.
So also ruhig auch sagen musst ja das ist jetzt auch wirklich man konnte der Brauch Video oder der lebt von Video der ist sozusagen besser durch.
Video oder ist nur durch Video zu machen dieser Canada ist da ein sehr sehr großer hat er jetzt weiß ich warum YouTube gut funktionieren kann,
dieser Channel muss sowieso kenne ist der Name ist extra Credits die machen viel zu Computerspielen.
Aber nicht nur also die jeden von die habe ich mir aber selber noch nicht angeschaut sie haben glaube ich einige Sendungen über Computerspiele,
Inhalte in Computerspielen also wirklich so von Genres über weibliche Charaktere also eine Vielfalt die sehr interessant ist bis hin zu seinem wie kann ich dem Developer werden oder was ist das überhaupt,
bis hinzu sie haben wir tun gerade sieht bei der neuesten Uploads einiges über history also geschickt Sachen wie Genghis Khan z.b.
und der Style den ihr haben es einfach so geil das macht Spaß ist es anzuschauen und zu wissen aufzusaugen,
lass jetzt mit Animation ne viel mit Animation du siehst keine Leute also die haben das wirklich.
Wunderbar gemacht das ist also ich finde sie sehr unterhaltsam und sehr informativ denn channel.
Und ich finde auch schön was sie da oben den haben wir Cars games matter sie versuchen halt auch so.
Rasse zeigen Warum Computerspiele halten nicht nur es ist halt so ein Computerspiel und du ballerst damit deine Zeit weg sondern ich versuche noch nicht auch noch ein bisschen so.
Mehr dazu stellen also warum es sind oder wertvoll ist dieses Spiel zu viel was man mit leeren kann oder keine Ahnung sag einfach ein cooler channel.
Eine meiner Lieblings Channel Lehrzeit als wenn ich mal wieder nicht weiß was ich machen könnte oder.
Der call langweilig ist in der Spritze.
Finde ich mich häufig auf dieser auf dieser YouTube Plattform dann YouTube wie Plattform wieder und gerade bei denen auf dem auf der Seite.
Habe gerade den geschichts Teil vor allem auch also ich höre ihn ganz gern geschichtspodcast und das heißt noch so eine gute komplementierung.
Alles was über Dschinghis Khan wissen müssen in 10 Minuten 21 mit lustigen.
Nein das ist ja ist er hat schon die description nicht richtig gelesen das ist part 4 was ist Folge 444 gibt es insgesamt.
Sprechen Sie das halt auch runter in unterschiedliche mehrere Folgen.
Und ich habe auch das zu bewerten geschaut weil ich den ganz ganz großartig finde.
Muss das ein bisschen schwierig zu ertragen wie die Englein englisch sprechende Menschen diesen Namen halt aussprechen ich habe erst gedacht ich gucken falsches video.
Ja ich habe irgendwie gerade heute.
Was hier frisch entdeckt das ist.
Das ist aber nicht im Ton an anspielen oder gibt's Typen Jared.
Und der irgendwie offensichtlich so 3D ganz gut kann und dann so Dinge erklärt indem man einfach komplette 3D Animationen draus macht so ne z.b. angeschaut hab so okay.
Das Weiße Haus in USA.
Man hört immer davon so auf was ist da genau drin so und da eben die Informationen dadrüber wie dieses Haus an die aufgebauter Sicherung ist hat öffentliche Information ist so hat er das hat einfach mal nach gemodelt.
Und mach dann halt so mit explosions so Mississippi die Etagen auseinander und erklärt sozusagen jeden einzelnen Raum jeden einzelnen Gang der irgendwie im Weißen Haus drin ist das in 6 Minuten,
und das in 6 Minuten soll ich meine was würdest du meinen wo befindet sich das Oval Office.
Eine Ahnung wahrscheinlich irgendwo in einem ganz unspektakulären Teil wahrscheinlich sogar unterhalb des Gebäudes weil.
Katja Fenster wo man rausgucken kann also sofern.
Wahrscheinlich Erdgeschoss würde ich vermuten ja wo irgendwo hinten oder so hin von was.
Also man sieht ja immer das weiß also wenn Reporter vor dem Weißen Haus stehen dann stehen sie ja immer,
vor dem Zaun und dann sieht man den Hintergrund das Weiße Haus Jan von der Perspektive aus betrachtet noch dahinter also genau aber es gibt ja dann auch noch Denise bringen und den Westring.
Keine Antwort wirklich also links und rechts anderen Gang entlang,
und der ist wegen ist halt so im Wesentlichen so Gästeempfang und noch mal irgendwie Platz für die First Lady und der Wrestling Restaurant da wo die eigentliche Regierung arbeitet und,
seitliche Weiße Haus auf das man schaut es halt eigentlich mehr oder weniger nur so ein reiner,
Gala und Wohnbereich also da wohnt man oder Ministerpräsidentin die Familie oder so und mit dem geilen Ausblick und den Fenstern den Zimmern.
Ja wenn man meinen Namen hat sie ist das Oval Office befindet sich einfach an der Ecke von diesem Westwing.
Die am Fenster gar keine Fenster sondern sind angestrahlt mit Tages Lampen Tageslichtlampen.
Na ja auf jeden Fall das dafür fand ich jetzt irgendwie YouTube mal wieder ganz praktisch natürlich ist eine ganze Menge zu entdecken das wissen wir ja alle so ein bisschen muss ich darauf hinzuweisen letztlich waren wir bei Formaten.
Und da kann man jetzt über Geschmack sicherlich streiten irgendwie ist für jeden was dabei aber.
Das bringt mich immer noch nicht dazu Video zu produzieren ich komme auch irgendwie mit Video nicht klar.
Glaube hat nur dann wirklich einen Mehrwert wenn du etwas zeigst weil ich habe irgendwie eine eine Person.
Von der Strecke ich sehr häufig irgendwie die ja die Strickmuster und jedes auch so einen djournal und diese Zeit auch so frontal vor der Kamera und das ja ab und zu zeigt jetzt mal so ein paar Sachen an den sie gerade arbeitet.
Dann ist es interessant aber ich finde halt auch da ist dieses YouTube so ein bisschen überflüssig,
also wenn ich dann finde ich das halt eher angenehm wirklich den Podcast zu haben weil sie halt auch versucht viel über,
den Prozess ihres Designs einfach zu erklären und so ein bisschen behaind bis hin zu Material zu geben er will ich dann halt doch lieber das ganze auf meinem Telefon haben mit dem ich dann in wie durch die Wohnung rennen kann und nicht irgendwie irgendwo YouTube und,
Wetter noch mal hingucken und keine Ahnung ich gucke YouTube Bänder nur auf dem iPad.
Da kann ich auch mal da in der Wohnung rumrennen erstellen.
Noch nicht nicht mehr Glastüren komm mir nicht in die Wohnung.
Apropos Radio deine Unfälle ja jetzt nicht mal mit einem Cappuccino Updates versorgen Hallo.
Previously on Cappuccino,
gute Frage ich weiß nicht was ich schon alles erzählt haben aber muss natürlich ist Kalle du musst jetzt noch mal die gesamte Story in hektischen jumpcut 30 Sekunden da passen.
Für die die noch nicht up to speed sind,
also da war dieses Auto was ich hatte das hatte ich sechs Tage und dann Elektroauto das Elektroauto einer Zoe Elektro,
achso Elektroauto erste Generation genau dann war da da dieser VW-Bus und dann war das Auto nur noch ein Schrotthaufen.
Das hatte ich schon erzählt alles was hatte ich noch erzählt ach ja das Auto hat das Auto hat eine lei Batterie.
Was den Fall etwas verkompliziert hat weil diese renault-bank so ein bisschen Schnarchnase ist moment mal kurz für mich der das jetzt nicht in ganze Blüte mitbekommen hat wird es noch mal wiederbelebt nein,
gut das Auto ist aber dass das jetzt auch eigentlich schon vorgegriffen aber egal ich ich fasse ich fasse mal den Ausgang der Geschichte zusammen aber ich habe gar keine Auto mehr.
Also es ist folgendermaßen.
Nach vielem Hin und Her habe ich also ich habe einen Gutachter beauftragt der dieses Auto begutachtet hat der hat ein Gutachten,
aber nicht schreiben wollen weil er der Meinung war er könnte ja die Batterie gar nicht begutachten dann hat es eine,
zwei drei Runden hin und her zwischen diversen Parteien gegeben bis ihm dann irgendjemand von der Renault Bank erklärt hat dass er doch bitte nur das Auto begutachten möge und,
nicht die Batterie und vor allen Dingen sein Gutachten reinschreiben soll dass das was er da als wert und so weiter bezieht sich nicht auf die Batterie und na ja dann hat er also sein Gutachten losgeschickt dann ging das irgendwie an die gegnerische Versicherung.
Und was ich also Neues gelernt habe in so einem Gutachten steht steht auch ein Restwert des Wracks drin ich nenn's mal frag.
Und zwar der wird dadurch ermittelt dass der Gutachter das Auto in eine Restwertbörse gibt.
Dort können Restwertaufkäufer die Reste dieses Autos kaufen und zwar bekommen die quasi das Gutachten gestellt,
woher Bilder dabei sind und wo er geschrieben hat was und wie und kaputten und so weiter und.
Und die können dann auf das Auto bieten interessanterweise ist ein Gebot bindend für ein paar Wochen also hier jemand der in der Restwertbörse auf das Auto bietet der muss das Geld dann auch bezahlen wenn der Besitzer des Autos sagt ja okay dann kaufst du das jetzt.
Soweit so gut also hat der Gutachter das Gutachten erstellt in dem Gutachten stand auch der Höchstbietende restwertkäufer drin,
und das Gutachten ging dann nicht nur zu meinem Anwalt und zu mir sondern auch zur Renault Bank.
Er muss das Mikro nähren die Renault Bank hat somit den Meistbietenden restwertkäufer.
Kontaktiert und ihn gefragt ob er denn nun eine Batterie bräuchte zusammen Schrotthaufen neben welchem Betrag ist im Moment ging.
Der Restwertaufkäufer hat 1250 € geboten.
Soweit wir halt gesagt wir müssen dass wir müssen es ganz langsam aufbauen er wird nämlich noch absurder so der Wert auf Käufer hat das daraufhin verneint.
Was auch sinnvoll ist weil nämlich die die Reparatur die der Fachhändler oder der der weiß ich nicht die zertifizierte Werkstatt in dem Fall halt hier Renault König in Berlin,
da so einen Kostenvoranschlag gemacht über drei Seiten mit tausenden Einzelposten und kamen irgendwie auf.
23.000 oder so also ich glaube mehr als das Auto ursprünglich neu gekostet hat,
okay das war jetzt der Oder ungefähr das nein das war die der der Kostenvoranschlag für eine Reparatur des Autos ist teurer als neues zu kaufen.
Ja so oder so in der Größenordnung also ohne Akku.
Wie gesagt dieses das Gutachten ging also an die gegnerische Versicherung was macht die gegnerische Versicherung,
das was natürlich so eine was man erwarten würde die Versicherung will das nicht bezahlen also lässt sie ein Gegengutachten oder Zweitgutachten erstellen.
Der Zweitgutachter hat im Wesentlichen zwei Sätze geschrieben.
Ja das erstgutachten passt soweit und B ja ich habe das Auto noch mal in eine Restwertbörse gegeben und da hat jemand mehr geboten.
Das heißt der zweit bieten der hat irgendwie 1600.
90 glaube ich mal ans geboten was natürlich dazu führt dass die Versicherung sich auf den Standpunkt steht ja der Restwert ist jetzt hör also teilen wir weniger.
Zu dem Wiederbeschaffungswert den der Gutachter in seinem Gutachten geschrieben.
Was mich natürlich dazu veranlasst hat zu sagen ja okay dann soll halt der Zweitgutachten Höchstbietende das Auto haben und habe dem das quasi angeboten.
Jetzt ist es aber so.
Dacia Renault Katja den Höchstbietenden aus dem erstgutachten gefragt ob er keine Batterie haben will.
Und der hat ja nein gesagt was dazu führte dass Reno,
diese Abwicklung mit der Batterie schon angestoßen hat und ich dann mit dem anderen da stand und dem,
quasi so er übrigens es gibt jetzt einen anderen Käufer und so weiter und sie wollen den doch bestimmt Anschreiben wegen der Batterie und so.
Sagt der Mann von der Renault Bank Jani für uns ist der für uns ist der Fall schon erledigt der Käufer will die Batterie ja gar nicht haben.
Und dann habe ich ihm er versucht erkennen ja aber ich habe das Auto nicht an diesen Herrn verkauft sondern an den anderen Herren und der könnte ja vielleicht eine Batterie haben wollen.
Warum sollte er für ein kaputtes Auto die Betreuer mal und dann sagt der Typ zu mir.
Ja nee das geht nicht dann müssen wir eine andere Transportkiste losschicken und das haben wir jetzt aber schon gemacht und die Kiste ist jetzt aus Frankreich unterwegs.
Weil nämlich die würden nämlich aus Frankreich eine frische Batterie in die Transport Kiste tun und nach Berlin schicken wenn eine frische Batterie in den Rest Haufen,
hätte eingebaut werden sollen damit sie dann eine leere Box haben um die kaputte Batterie zurückzuschicken aber es wollen noch keine Batterie haben Nachtisch.
Wollte dir eine zweite Koffer eine Batterie haben ich weiß es nicht als ich nicht dazu geäußert hin das überhaupt gefragt sofakombi egal.
Ich kann dir das nicht vollkommen egal ja im Prinzip schon und etwas kompliziert.
Also ja und jetzt mal zusammenzufassen du hast den Schrott,
Wagen jetzt für 1600 irgendwas verkauft genau das geht geht dir direkt zu das was beste ich habe diesen,
den daB da diese Restwertbörse da quasi kontaktiert angerufen meinte ja hier und soweit ich würd es machen meinte ja ja ich schicke Ihnen den Vertrag zu und bla und die die abholvollmacht das unterschrieben und gescannte wieder hingeschickt und,
ja ja der soll das Geld überweisen wenn das Auto geholt hat einen Tag später hatte ich das Geld auf dem Konto nicht so hell.
Rufe wird Reno an ja ist denn das Auto schon ab müde und das steht da noch hat sich auch noch keiner gemeldet Geld überwiesen das Auto zu haben je gesehen zu haben.
Ach ja ja okay so und dann hat er inzwischen also das Auto abgeholt jetzt ist aber Renault immer noch der Meinung dass der andere das Auto abgeholt hätte.
Es ist alles absolut also bei Renault und dann nicht überhaupt garnichts aber das mal tranzit kriegst du denn jetzt also sind jetzt klar dass du Sonntag auch eine Versicherungssumme jetzt auch bezahlt.
Kommst ja die habe ich auch schon bekommen also eigentlich ist jetzt schon alles gut.
Eigentlich ist jetzt schon alles Gute Zeiten irgendwann ruft mich jemand an und fragt wie es wurde Vakuolen,
aber ansonsten ist eigentlich alles gut ach und Reno.
Könnte ich tun aber ich habe jetzt wieder das Auto noch die die Papiere die sind jetzt alle beim Aufkäufer.
Du hast schon einen Kaufvertrag wo drin steht das erst ummelden muss und so.
Wird es Auto sowieso nie wieder fahren nee klar aber du musst jetzt mit der Versicherung sagen dass du jetzt nicht mehr fährst ja.
Was ist ein Totalschaden.
Wissenschaft der Versicherung vollkommen aber keine Autoversicherung ist das ja vollkommen egal ich freue mich wenn du weiter überweist.
Also wenn du die Totalschaden irgendwie scheiße an der Kreuzung geparkt lässt und jemand rein fährt,
müsste dir auch Zeit also das ist vielmehr von daher wäre es geboten anzuzeigen dass du jetzt sozusagen das verkauft hast Datum Uhrzeit,
und damit er geht dann nämlich automatisch würde die dann löschen du bist dann raus okay naja Schrotthaufen auf der Kreuzung steht,
und da fährt einer rein dann bist du halt potenziell dafür haftbar und kann ich eine Haftpflichtversicherung na ja.
Versicherungswelten das ist ein tolles Thema das gucke ich mir gleich nachdem ich mit Buchhaltung fertig sind,
Bilder mir langweilig ist Metaebene Versicherung ja,
aber halt Masochismus ala Tim Pritlove wie teuer das ist voll Buchhaltungsfirma ist für dich also haben ja ganz so bin ich doof wenn ich das vorher gewusst hätte was das,
was hast du die Tiefe hat und so also würdest du ja gar nicht sitzen nee hätte ich mich,
sag Schweineschnitzel im Prozess dass einem langsam erstmal bewusst die ganze Zeit falsch gemacht hat.
Habe jetzt immer noch beim Cappuccino ne ja genau das ist die Frage die alle Interessierten gebrandmarkt und denkst dir nie wieder Elektro oder.
Mit Elektro hat das ja erstmal nichts zu tun.
Also ich meine das Auto vor einige die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen gehört ne deswegen ist er hatte die Vorfahrt.
Hat das kann durchaus sein der hat ein Diesel gefahren die sind ja nicht ganz leise.
Ja doch wahrscheinlich also nee ist ja ich werde ein neues Auto kaufen auch wieder das gleiche Modell.
Möglicherweise nicht exakt das gleiche Modell aber momentan ist zumindest so im unteren Preissegment bei Renault kriegt man noch irgendwie das meiste fürs Geld.
Ja also alles tut sie ja auch Wiesenmarkt eigentlich eine Menge aber irgendwie auch nix.
Beerenobst jetzt stärkere Motoren Handy so ist ein ja das ist genau das was wir gebraucht haben,
und es gibt sie in lila lila metallic sieht ziemlich cool aus,
also ich meine.
Wie kommt die Frage auf ob ich mir nicht ein Model 3 reserviert habe ja habe ich aber ich werde dieses Jahr 10.
Das könnte noch dauern weiche.
Ja ich stelle immer wieder fest dass das eigentlich sich alle total verrannt haben.
Und was sie mich eigentlich wundere ist warum warum eigentlich überhaupt keine Chinesen auf dem Markt sind nicht auf dem deutschen Markt.
Der also der Liebe Vivaldi Vivaldi ist wissen die wenigsten im Westen der Hersteller der weltweit die meisten Elektroautos verkauft hat.
Ja aber die Einstellung und das sind auch die dir in shengjin wie viel waren,
30.000 Busse 30000 Elektrobusse mal eben hingestellt haben wir soll eine 16000 die glaube ich oder 16000 keine Ahnung ich habe dann mal die Zahl nachgeguckt für Berlin sind so 1200 Busse oder so.
Irgendwie sowas in der Gegend gesamt insgesamt e-busse sein aber interessanterweise sind auch genauso viele s-bahnwagen und U-Bahnwagen und Straßenbahnwagen.
So um die 1000 1000 bis 1200 je nach einzelne Wagen ja wie Busse.
Käme dann also so in Berlin so ungefähr auf 4000 bis 5000,
Wagen davon halt dreiviertel elektrisch weil die S-Bahn U-Bahn und Straßenbahn elektrisch fährt insofern finde ich das eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt was der Rest der Berliner Nahverkehr der macht.
Kann ich dich rumheulen dass wir nur drei Elektrobusse haben aber wir haben halt dreiviertel des rollenden Materials fährt elektrisch.
Man könnte schon rumheulen dass du überhaupt so einen Missverhältnis haben zwischen Straßenbahnen und Bussen,
die Autos die Straßenbahnschienen verstopfen wenn es gibt in Berlin so ganz kluge Menschen die an zwei oder drei Punkten so eine Straßenbahn von ihrer.
Mittelspur wo die Autos nicht fahren dürfen was wirklich abgetrenntes auf die auf die Fahrbahn lassen und oh Wunder jeden Morgen kommt es genau an diesen Stellen zum Staunen du denkst sie so,
warum warum kann man diesen Teil dann wenigstens nicht in der Rush-Hour einfach sagen wird gesperrt da darf kein Auto lang,
damit man wenigstens in der Bahn sitzt und ankommen will sie du fragst dich doch immer was mit Twitter anfangen sollst du könntest irgendwie auch diesen ganzen Rage Fahrrad,
Wetter wann beitreten den ganzen Tag geschockte Fotos von Falschparkern posten,
ganz viel lieber an meinem Schlüsselbund oder irgendwo an meinem Bein so eine Sonne.
Spitzes Gerät haben um den schönen Autofahrern vor allem im Wedding einfach Kurzinfos rauszuhalten und eine schöne Kerbe rein machen das will mit dir lieber Freund,
bitte Karl nein doch nein ich will nur letzte oder ver 2 Wochen irgendwie aus auf die Idee gekommen von Mitte nach Tegel zu fahren und im Prenzlauer Berg nach Tegel im Prenzlauer Berg und.
Wo ich das so lange wunderbar die Welt echt noch heil und dann kam ich so in den Wedding und ich dachte mir es mir passiert.
Ja nichts also deshalb haben sie dich halt um.
Zwillings okay hallo hier ist so nennt sich Fahrradweg Entschuldigung ist ja auch auf der Straße bin.
Aber jetzt ein anderer insistiert sind Gesellschaft kulturelle Aspekte neu jetzt auf brings ich wollte eigentlich gerne noch bei den Bussen bleiben weil es ja eilig,
staatlichen Bereich ist wo sich gerade überhaupt irgendwas tut also unter anderem hat er als Netflix gesagt,
wo ist jetzt auch irgendwie zwischen Frankreich diesen expandieren ja irgendwie auch in Ordnung Frankreich nehmen Sie jetzt die erste Buslinie in Betrieb natürlich nicht mit dem europäischen Bus Modell weil gibt keins ranhalten chinesischen,
woanders auch ganz interessant wie die das so rechnen,
Neumann du nachher da Wert eurer so aber ausserdem spart man sich eine ganze Menge Sprit weil so dir ein Treibstoffkosten sind halt bei Elektro dann doch niedriger ansteckzeit weniger Strom als in Benzin.
Aber diese und außerdem wäre ja dann auch die Infrastruktur schon da.
Paris und Anja wo das Ding auf ihre Tiere Thurzo du hast mir so die anderen nicht,
beklagt aber ist schon irgendwie absurd trotzdem so als Auto Ersatz ist halt irgendwie echt wenig.
Das tut sich einfach wenig gibt halt irgendwie jetzt die Zoe seit Jahren,
Gasheizung wie viel viel Geld in London Tesla Luxusmobil stecken so das rechnet sich nie.
Achso du bist jetzt nicht so für durchschnittlichen Geldbeutel interessanterweise sind halt nur sagen weil die beiden Autos die wirklich überteuert sind im mit kurzer Lieferzeit,
verfügbar das wäre halt mal ein Tesla,
also nicht Model 3 von den anderen beiden den du innerhalb von 6 Wochen kriegen kannst und Zoe Weile gebraucht oder i3 den du innerhalb von sechs Wochen als Neuwagen kriegen kannst aber du hast beim Ritual,
die 3 kriegt man 6 Wochen ja aber du zahlst halt's ungefähr das Doppelte wert ist so als als Auto aber ist Zoe.
Hat ein halbes Jahr Lieferzeit E-Golf hat glaube ich auch fast ein halbes Jahr Lieferzeit Hyundai ioniq hat über ein Jahr Lieferzeit das ist ja wir müssten das ist WMS was ne,
und und,
na du merkst halt du weißt halt bei den Händlern stehen halt die ganzen Titel rum die wären sie nicht los über werben sie für ihre ihre Zusatzprämie in die du kriegst wenn du dann Diesel kaufst ne.
Das ist so ja ja genau der Zoe Konfigurator ist ein Flash hat mir leid,
hatte jemals jemand geschrieben in im Chat ist es auch so übel ich dachte im Schwimmen installierst du dir jetzt einen Mac OS in der virtuellen Maschine nur um die Hand anhalten,
na da habe ich es dann halt von Firmenlaptop ausgemacht auch Gulasch,
das hübsche weiß es nicht genau also du kannst das auch noch auf dem Safari zum laufen kriegen aber du musst dann sozusagen nur einmal mal sagen Ja ich will das,
wirklich jetzt hier wird es mir auch recht ich finde es auch richtig Aldi sollte man es noch schlimmer machen alles sollte man einfach automatisch,
alle Webseiten abspielen wo Flash ist und da die Dos Attacken auf,
aber hier gegen den Autos sein du bist hier der radikale.
Lämmchen na ja ich weiß nicht wie es mit dem Nissan Leaf ist es gibt ja diesen neuen Nissan Leaf,
mit dem größeren Akku und dem halbwegs brauchbaren Aussehen der erste Seil ganz furchtbar aus.
Wie da die Lieferzeit ist aber angeblich kann man die tatsächliche innerhalb ordentlicher Zeit bekommen also,
nee das ist irgendwie sind sie alle überfordert niemand hat das irgendwie wahrhaben wollen und also ich denke in zwei.
2 Jahren ist Erding durch also dann dann lauft ihr auch gefühlt bei nahezu allen die.
Die Portion auch wirklich an also egal wohin du jetzt schaust alle.
Alle was an also alles was angekündigt dass es irgendwie so 20 Uhr 19:20 Uhr 20 Uhr das heißt dann dann wirds halt auch so langsam mal.
Spannend zu sehen so und dann hoffentlich auch mehr als nur deine Pendler mini Autos und.
Luxus-SUV Samstag was gibt's noch.
Der interessanterweise was ich lustig finde bei Magna gefertigt wird ist es ja diese diese Autohöfe durch Autohersteller der so Auftragsarbeiten macht und die haben,
ja das einfach keine Möglichkeit den zu bauen also müssen sie es wir das ist so dass focalpoint für Autos genau ja.
Da mir auch alles so ein bisschen die also einen an Apples Produktionsstraße geglaubt haben auch so immer vermutet dass sie dann irgendwie an der Stelle vielleicht mit reingrätschen.
Finde ich auch ein sehr günstiges Gerät dieser Jaguar.
So ab 70 60 70 +79 aufwärts ja gut.
Ja irgendwie irgendwie gibt's nichts zwischen ganz billig und ganz teuer das ist auch ein bisschen merkwürdig denen E-Autos ist die Zoe eigentlich das günstigste in Deutschland.
Hat mich bisher den Anschein gemacht als wäre dieses Jahr wenn du wirklich ganz dünn also Neuwagen wenn du den den günstigsten ist glaube ich aus der Ehe ab ist relativ günstig.
Aber das ist auch alles okay aber glaube ich ganz schlimm also der ist ja schon ein Benziner schlimm und dann gibt's halt noch den den smart smart.
Ja der ist der E-Smart ist deutlich teurer als der Smart aber der Ehe ab ist auch teurer deutlich teurer als der ab nicht macht hattet Haare auch als die Zoey.
Na Zoe kriegst du lass mich nichts falsches sagen ich glaube ab 28 oder so neu.
20-22.
Na ja dann vielleicht doch umbauen ist ein Kollege,
bei mir einer Firma hat seinen alten Volvo Kombi zum E-Auto umgebaut und jetzt ganz happy damit ja aber da musst du erstmal drivetrain kriegen also es gibt ja das von der Lektüre BWT die Zoe Pionierin,
Jana die sowas mit dem VW Bus machen möchte und sie kommt ums verrecken nicht an einen Motor samt Ansteuerung irgendwie Weiber will ihr nichts verkaufen,
und ja bis ich meinen Kollegen fragen wo der sein Zeug her hatte ich garnicht dass man das auch machen kann also ich meine so ein schöner schicke alter Volvo,
würde mir auch das Herz ich weiß nicht ob er den Vortrag schon öffentlich mal gehalten hat es war bei so einem firmeninternen eventart mal vorgestellt und hatte nur noch reichlich Bilder dabei und es war.
Wirklich sehr sehr cool weil,
hatte ich ja glaube ich auch schon mal gesagt hast halt eben nicht diese ganzen digitalen Plastik Armaturen sondern da bewegen sich dann immer noch die zeige und dann hast du halt irgendwie Batteriestatus ist halt auch so ein schönes,
Voltmeter Einbau quasi Nase hat auf jeden Fall einen schönen Retro-Charme ne.
Muss ich fragen mal wenn ich dran denke na ja auf jeden Fall ist Elektrobusse glaube ich sind irgendwie doch die sinnvollere Geschichte weil die einfach.
Besseres Lösung ist in einfacher,
systemisch aufzustellen als Autos also normal personalanforderung von von individuellen Nutzern sind halt so unterschiedlich,
dass ich da extrem viel der wird Diversität erstmal ausbilden muss die natürlich ja nicht entsteht solange die Nachfrage nicht da ist die halt nicht da ist und Diversität ist und so weiter,
der Bus nicht so wie klar dann so viele Leute reinpassen das Ding fährt so viel Kilometer und brauchst ein Bein stellen irgendwie Strom so und dann ist noch die Frage wie schnell lädt das Ding,
und was kostet es und wie viel Strom verbraucht S&P Reisekosten hast du dadurch dass du so eine hohe Kilometerzahl hast ja relativ schnell wieder drin.
Na also diese kriegst du ja nicht umsonst und wahrscheinlich ist es auch leichter als Verkehrsunternehmen irgendwie sich eine Ladeinfrastruktur hinzustellen.
SMS ich habe doch mit meinem Opa drüber geredet der ist ja auch voll Feuer und Flamme für so E-Mobilität was das angeht und ich meinen alle reden immer nur so in der Stadt in der Stadt aber ich glaube halt auch wenn man das ordentlich ausbauen würde das ladesäulennetz würde das auf dem Land,
fast noch noch besser funktionieren also das Land hat ja jeder.
Was jeder in Rage und Parkplatz und hältst du diese typischen Wege dann fährst du zum Einkaufen das heißt wenn du so erklärt Supermärkte damit auch aus Statisten.
Dann hast du ja auch wieder,
Mehrwert was meint er der nette Hörer der mich da in Züricher mit seinem gebrauchten Tesla abholte dass er jetzt in der Garage keine la also hat da keine.
Schnelllade Option und so erkennen Sie daran so eine Steckdose hängen aber dann wird er ja auch nicht fertig und er fährt halt dann,
einmal die Woche einkaufen und stellst dann eben dran beim Baumarkt da ist wohl so Ladesäulen Territorium das reicht dann weder für die ganze Woche ja aber das ist das ist natürlich auch so einen Sohn so eine alte,
ist ein altes Missverständnis du musst ihn ja nicht über Nacht voll machen du musst ja nur über Nacht soviel reinladen.
Wie du auch tatsächlich verwehrt halt trotzdem einfach nur so eine,
Garage wo irgendwie was weiß ich das halt nur eine Sicherung Fernlicht heiße.
Sie müssen sich bewegen,
ja das ist bei einem Tesla relativ einfach wenn er so wird schon schwierig übrigens die BVG hatte irgendwie jetzt neulich eine Abordnung in China um mal deren Elektrobusse auch anzugucken.
Also ist es sind nicht nur also irgendwie gucken alle jetzt nach China weil die bauen die Elektrobusse die tatsächlich funktionieren hat man das Gefühl,
Radio Bob gibt ja alle Zettel bei der Vorstellung ihrer e-busse gleich gesagt dass wir das ja nicht empfehlen könnten,
Mittelfeld bei der Forschung so naja so wäre es eigentlich cooler haben wir darauf dass die beim Diesel Bus ja,
wer wird neuer Verkehrsminister ist eine von diesen ich habe schon wieder gelesen danke wir sollten stolz darauf sein auf diese Diesel herum schaffe Gangster,
wer hat eigentlich dir Schlüssel hat ausfüllen aber es ist echt so dingse so.
Hätte mir die einfach nicht in Ordnung also gar nicht was ist das für ein Minister,
wo ist deine Bewerbung eigentlich von Diesel.
Ja aber der der Benz Typ hat doch auch behauptet er würde die Physik nicht verstehen weil irgendwie das was Tester da mit dem Truck machen will das könnte ja nicht genau also irgendwie die.
Die deutsche Physik leider irgendwie anders als ein bisschen anders formuliert aber ja ja die Umrechnung mit Sicherheit.
Die Meilen sind bestimmt werden noch warten müssen so also ich denke ich werde auch über eine Zwischenlösung nicht hinwegkommen war das.
Da fällt über den Elektrobussen jetzt aber und du denn der Zwischenlösung ein wenn man dann so ein Elektro Wasser kaufen kann dann hätte man ja auch ein schönes Reisegefährte also wenn man sie sich dann noch aufbauen kann in nicht mit,
weil die sehe ich gerade die kann man ab 8, 7 Meter kaufen und nicht nur die 18 m Variante.
Vergleichen Reisegefährt mit dem du unterwegs sein kannst alle sind ja immer darauf sich ein Wohnwagen oder ein Bus zu kaufen und auszubauen kannst du mein Evos kaufen zeigen,
der hat er noch keine Probleme wenn es mal ein bisschen bergauf geht der hatte so einen Tesla semi truck kaufen und dann R14 Anhänger,
ja wenn diese tiny House Bewegung ist schon irgendwie eine Zahnreinigung,
ja ja da muss erstmal ein Parkplatz befindet kannst du einfach verstehst du dumm Gewerbegebiet ist nicht so schön,
Uhr auf Autobahnparkplätzen Friedhof,
Medisana.
Ich habe irgendwann mal so einen krassen Bus Doppeldecker Bus Ausbau zum Wohnmobil ausgegraben hat mir das hier.
Nee ich muss mich ich muss spontan an unsere gemeinsame Begegnung auf einem Festival denke ja na ja das ist ne andere.
Kategorie sitze aber so so in der Richtung weil hier noch alle da müssen wir das Video noch mal raussuchen,
hat das og ausführlich gepostet wie er sich halt so,
Doppeldeckerbus gekauft hatten den halt komplett entkernt hat und dann so nach seinem Gusto,
zugeschnitten hat Soda mit großen fetten Schlafzimmer dann so oben hinten,
oben noch irgendwie die die die die Sitze nach vorne auch noch so so als Lümmel Zone unten und kleine Wohnzimmer Bereich mit Küche Pipapo natürlich ordentlich Akkus rein irgendwie örtliche Stromversorgung Klimaanlage das volle Programm,
das hat sich irgendwie neisna es gibt ja auch so du kannst ja auch so Dinge mieten Wie heißen noch mal diese Teile.
Gib zum mietbusse die ausgebaut sind quasi als Hotel.
Hotel na ja budu na ja wo du so 4563 glaube bis 8 Uhr Betten drin hast,
bei mir sogar noch zwölf verdammte Axt wie heißt der noch mal.
Doch du sollst du das denn der Bus hat glaube ich jemand überlegt und den Rest Zusteller.
Die sind ganz normal bei Benz diese Touren die holen sich so ein teil und dann fahren sie von Kik zu Kik und beende meine Bus ja.
Was zumindest die größeren die sich das leisten können genau sowas meinte ich.
Ich muss also wahrscheinlich schon seit 100 Jahren aber irgendwie habe ich das nie so richtig auf den Zeiger gehabt aber die sind sauer, wenn es mit mehreren Leuten unterwegs bist durchaus genau der Schlafwagen leistbar genau.
Schon wieder ist Neid Neid Neid.
Gasmelder wieder genug Leute zusammenkommen nimmt auch nicht so viel Platz weg.
Also dann halt auch im Wesentlichen nur so schlafen aber muss ich so ein bisschen um die oder hast wahrscheinlich noch eine Runde ortliche Dusche drinnen,
das weiß ich nicht ich habe das nur auf der Mailingliste so am Rande gelesen habe musste darüber sehr schmunzeln ich muss an so ein Hostel denken so mobiles Hostel.
Gut und zu anderen Themen voranschreiten.
Welche anderen Themen Mobilfunkverträge z.b. Aachen,
Käse pro Tag oder was nehmt ihr bei Verbrauch 2 Gigabyte wenn ich nichts mache,
wahrscheinlich doch die ganze Zeit.
Natürlich gucke ich mich mit Tour alles ich tue alles ich tue immer alles genau gleich egal wo ich bin wenn ich was sehen will dann schaue ich mir das an.
So deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade an meiner Flatrate 100 Megabit DSL-Leitung sitze oder irgendwo 3G Schnorchel die Daten müssen fließen.
Und zwar in Mathe Richtung manchmal auch von mir weg so auf dem Bedarf habe ich zuerst ganz schön Bedarf dass Daten von dir wegfließen glaube ich also ich habe,
ich kämpfe es ist saumäßig kritisch oft viele Monate im Jahr ist es kritisch dass ich mit meinen 30 Gigabyte überhaupt über die Runden kommen,
mobil jetzt Monate angelogen.
Ja ich meinte du hast WLAN schon auch anderen Phone ja ich habe WLAN Empfang aber wenn ich halt irgendwo unterwegs bin so.
Oder dumm zum Dusslingen Hotel wo das Hotel WLAN halt so ist Hotel WLAN war schon okay,
weiterreden,
habe die Zeit dann nicht weil ich halt was hochladen muss oder weil ich das runterladen muss oder weil mir halten und Fakten lassen anschauen will dir halt sonst nicht funktioniert oder nicht in der richtigen Qualität kommt so oder Jubel ich dann halt gerne meine Gigabyte aufwecken weil das,
Hochdahl.
Internet einfach mal so Gigabyte kostet kostet diese Mobilfunkbetreiber einfach ein Scheiß.
Ja das wird verkauft wie Goldplättchen Belag und es ist einfach mal ein Witz das kostet die nix,
und deswegen ist dieser ganze leise Circus deiner veranstaltet wird in Deutschland ist halt einfach Albatros kam die Telekom um die Ecke.
Herz als total gut jetzt machen wir hier irgendwie mal richtige Flatrate sich auf schön diese Formulierung so voll Datenflatrate richtig könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern als das mit diesem Flatrates anfing Flat und alle Netze.
Was ist eine Flatrate war damals den Begriff für Flatrate,
Schulzeiten Festbetrag und dann hast du mit,
wann kam die Pauschale nannte man das mal raus die halt irgendwie eine 10 Gigabyte flat was daran Flat ist habe ich bis heute noch nicht verstanden außer vielleicht die Hirne die sie sowas haben einfallen lassen,
Manuel Neuer seitdem diese ganze Tortur und es wird irgendwie alles ja teuer teuer verscherbelt ne ich meine irgendwie mit Svenja in Deutschland verkauft wie Koks,
zu den Preisen du kannst dich ja länger anhält ne,
von Ronny,
also.
Schlimm also was ist jetzt das Angebot jetzt kommt irgendwie an mit einer Stimme bei diesen 200 € und dann ist es wirklich Flat so ist nicht ganz so mein liebes Kind also 200 €.
Schwierig am jetzt haben wir einen 80 € Tarif ausgepackt.
Na ja ich habe mal versucht irgendwie das Kleingedruckte zu versteht ist mir nur sehr eingeschränkt gelungen weil irgendwie auch alles so verklausuliert ist man weiß aber nicht so ganz genau so z.b. so für Privatkunden kostet dann halt.
Eine zusätzliche SIM-Karte für diesen Vertrag kostet halt noch mal 30 € im Monat.
War ja so eine kleine SIM-Karte auch unheimlich teuer ist ne da müsste damit diese Produktionskosten die werden die werden auf dem Mars wenn die gestanzt,
müssen erstmal mit SpaceX wieder zurück geflogen werden das findet ja auch erst in 20 Jahren statt mit meinem Kollegen bin so eine Mädchen Teeshop irgendwie in Ameland,
und haben wir da so gefragt ja wie ist denn hier ist so mit SIM-Karte und Daten und so weiter und weiter ja SIM Karte kostet 50 $ und wir sind in die schallendes Gelächter ausgebrochen beide und der Typ D,
wusste nicht wie ihm geschieht,
also irgendwie der hat das nicht verstanden dass das jetzt eigentlich das auch nie anders also das ist auch noch ein bisschen schlimmer also es ist ein USA es ist noch schlimmer,
weil ja noch mehr oligopoly ja haben als wir aber es ist halt auch nicht schön und so jetzt haben wir halt das.
80 € soll dann.
Dachte mir so okay alles klar das heißt so für meinen Use Case kann ja gleich mal 60 € drauf legen wir halt schon mal bei wir schon mal waren da,
140 € war schon mal uninteressant dann gibt's jetzt wohl irgendwie noch so in der aber wenn du den irgendwie klar machen kannst dass du Geschäftskunde bis dann gibt's halt auch kostenlos ich bin ja auch so was für ein Trip auf dann wiederum von,
privater Geschäftskunden hätten extreme Einschränkungen.
Ich kann gut sein wie gesagt mir ich habe versucht das zu verstehen die Information zu konsumieren aber sie wurde einem auch nicht ausreichend da gemacht oder vielleicht war ja auch zu blöd dazu Verzierung in meinem Chat noch genauere Erkenntnisse dazu etwas wieder Tarif ist macht oder nicht macht,
bitte sehr dass es bis jetzt gerade mein Verständnis davon dazu kommt dann noch dass sie dann halt und auch da bin ich mir nicht so hundertprozentig sicher dass.
Wurde mir von Menschen so gesagt dass sie das so verstanden hätten entweder ist Tethering gar nicht eingeschaltet oder unterliegt dann irgendwie wiederum so ein Verjus.
Den Klamotten,
aber halt nicht so viel ich halt nur sagen kann das ist einfach mal ich meine geht's noch ich will einfach nur den Internet scheiße an und.
Ende work on dass sie mir nicht,
107 dazugeben die alle über diesen selben Tarif laufen habe ich auch wie ein gewisses Verständnis dafür trotzdem muss ich halt mal in die weißes bedient bekommen ich habe dann halt noch ein iPad und ich.
Brauche halt auch noch in meinem Router so weil dafür,
ist es da oder verzeihe ich dann wieder Geld und dann fließt das Geld und schließen die Daten und alle sind glücklich,
einfach wirklich ist nicht zu fassen ich freue mich natürlich auch so wo ist denn jetzt eigentlich das was man eigentlich bezahlen sollte.
Also was was würdet ihr denn jetzt mal unabhängig von dem was gerade angeboten wird was würdet ihr denn als fair ansehen was das für die denn sagen ist ein marktgerechter anwendungs gerechter Preis für,
nicht mehr nachdenken müssen über Grenzen.
Also ich kann dir ja weiß nicht was gerechtfertigt ist aber ich würde klicken weil.
100 € Monat für keine weiteren Fragen alle Türen offen mit mit mit Sim.
Karten dazu soll ich das geschrieben habe wie viel SIM-Karten achso 3.
Honey.
Dann aber auch wirklich keine Tethering keine Fragen einfach shut up and take my money leicht soll ich sogar,
aber nee eigentlich so 100 ist doch so eine Grenze da würde ich noch so mitgehen Alter würdest du das für dich ich ne na ja gut,
aber hast du aber ich sag mal das wäre so meine Schmerzgrenze ne wo ist wohl oder die Grenze wo ich noch überlegen also wo ich.
Nicht überlegen oder aber das sage ich jetzt auch als LTE arbeitende Menschen mit jetzt nicht dem kleinsten verdienten ja aber natürlich weniger ist immer besser also der Profi.
Irgendwie ist mir fast noch so viel weil wenn ich jetzt mal Vergleiche was will ich,
vor ein paar Jahren irgendwie so ein Internetanschluss für zu Hause gekostet hat wohl irgendwie bei 20 € im Monat dabei bin.
Vielleicht nicht die schnellste Verbindung aber.
Aber soviel wie ich will dann denke ich mir halt so okay ich wäre bereit für etwas mehr Geld zu bezahlen also vielleicht dann auch die für den Fuffi wenn ich nur noch ein.
Also einen Anbieter für zu Hause und mobil habe und irgendwie SIM-Karten 3 oder 4 hat eine für zu Hause 3 für Geräte die mobile sind auch wenn ich die z.b. selber nicht bräuchte einfach um das zu sagen wäre geil oder 5.
Dann wäre ich gleich mit meinem Profil für unlimited irgendwie bereit aber eigentlich denke ich mir auch bei dem Fuji habt ihr eigentlich ein an der Waffel.
Also ich kann dir selbst nicht so viel aber ich kann halt nicht einschätzen was die also.
Balkan Überblick was zum Beispiel der Mehraufwand an Infrastruktur für Funk,
das ist Internet alles so dass da habe ich keinen Bezugspunkt kann ich nicht einschätzen deswegen kann ich nicht sagen was darf er so oder so wahrscheinlich gibt's in irgendwelchen Geschäftsberichten von der Telekom oder sonst was wo man das runterladen für die man ja wahrscheinlich einsehen kann,
irgendwelche Kosten Punkte dafür aber,
sag mal so wenn ich jetzt so ganz blauäugig daran Hyundai okay ist jetzt vielleicht auch total teuer irgendwie Funkmast Netzwerk und Bandbreite und Abdeckung und wenn man das wirklich überall haben will unsere kostet halt viel mehr Geld blablabla dann wie gesagt wurde.
Vielleicht ganz blauäugig das glauben will dann kann ich auch mit diesen 100 € leben aber wenn sich am Ende raus stellt das ist jetzt auch.
Garnicht mal so teuer dann will ich aber auch an der gesamten U Bahn von Berlin immer gutes Netz habe.
Derzeit gibt es nämlich nur an den Bahnhöfen edge.
Generell in Berlin nichts mehr unter 3G also ich meine wenn du so in einigen ordnen Berlin bist denkst ja auch manchmal so hoch.
Wo bist du also es ist mit welchem Mobilfunknetz und von wo versichert ich habe Telekom.
Aber in einigen Wochen Telekom du hast immer nur EDGE ja das ist seit einiger Zeit irgendwie so ich habe mal früher fand ich gab es an einigen Stellen etwas da wo ich U-Bahn gefahren bin habe ich morgen guten gute Verbindung aber,
nee das U-Bahn-Netz hat ursprünglich bei E-Plus aufgebaut.
Und die scheinen in die sind jetzt mit o2 zusammen gegangen und die scheinen irgendwie inzwischen auch so ein bisschen nach renoviert zu haben,
aber ich glaube das nur Eplus und o2 tatsächlich dann das Gute Netz bekommen und die anderen Roamingpartner bekommen hat das edge.
Bitte U-Bahn schafften ja na ja sieht da dran dass das Netz von o2 ist ja also das war ja das Ding womit die gestartet sind damals.
Soweit ich weiß hat das E-Plus Gebäude supernett E-Plus ist o2 gerade gesagt hör mal zu,
du hast gesagt er o2 behindert.
Ist halt nur EDGE also oder soll ich bitte eine an Höfen ist dieses WLAN von der von von der von der BVG aber du merkst ja deutlich sie haben wahrscheinlich an jedem Bahnhof nur einen.
Access Point und die U-Bahn fährt so rein dann kriegst du ein paar mehr Balken impressum paar weniger Balken und dann ist auch schon wieder Feierabend finding wenn so eine vollbesetzte U-Bahn direkt an einen Accesspoint ran fährt dann war's das glaube ich auch schon wieder.
Also irgendwie das ist so wann fahren macht kein Spaß.
Also mich würde echt mal interessieren was die kosten für den für die Bereitstellung der Infrastruktur dafür ist und was halt auch echt einfach nervig ist.
Warum nennt man nicht irgendwie alle an einem Strang ziehen können und sagen hier einheitliche Infrastruktur und die jeder Netzbetreiber kann sich darauf rein mieten aber.
Nicht hier irgendwie in der U-Bahn bräuchtest du eigentlich o2 aber sonst überall willst du vielleicht E-Plus haben also es ist halt bloß er schon Telekom.
Weiß nicht was weiter machen wir kommen nicht vorwärts.
Firma aus der Abteilung Jubiläen die stattfinden und sich an drohen.
Erstmal irgendwie vor 20 Jahren The Big Lebowski rausgekommen ist das endlich ein Film über die Welt letzte Mal auch gestritten haben oder wann wir zahlen den habe ich gesehen,
Nippes auch gut natürlichen fresse dich ja jetzt ein bisschen ne.
Finde ich auch beim abgesagt warum haben wir hier keinen keinen White Russian auf dem Tisch stehen.
Ja Essen mitbringen können,
letzter Jedi Standardausstattung der Betaine sowie die Cocktailbar ist jetzt hier noch nicht eingepreist aber ich habe irgendwie was man tun kann sogar sein dass ich aus alten NSFW,
bestimmt mir noch irgendwie schlechten Wodka oder sowas rumley stehen habe,
das Wort hätte ich weiß auch nicht aber was taugt.
Darauf darauf wollte ich ja nicht hinaus so Big Lebowski sollten wir aber alle irgendwie auf derselben Seite oder über die Seite auf der man sein kann,
na die einzige Seite wieder aufgeschlagen werden kann Anja,
kennst du den essential Card hattet ihr einen letztes Mal gegessen hat wohl jemand fünf Minuten,
zusammengebaut geh auf fünf Minuten zusammengeschnitten Haltestelle Wolfach sagt genau ja das finde ich so geil,
ja also werde ich weiß wovon wir reden The Big Lebowski ist für dich alle großartigen Beiträge zur Filmgeschichte und Wittrock.
Total,
ey du drin außerdem damit in zehn Jahren fast vor zehn Jahren,
hat dieser Podcast mal angefangen zu senden dazugehört.
Ja mehr oder weniger also Anfänger sind natürlich ob der das Zeitraums mir jetzt nicht mehr so super präsent aber ich kann mich sehr gut an die Nullfolge erinnern wo ich dachte so hä was geht was wird denn das jetzt.
Die nullte die Null wäre ich glaube es war die Leute diese Pilotfolge gar nicht für die in die Pilotfolge zweiten Sohn Sound Clip,
ja na ja aber zwei so ein feet Füller,
genau so ein defätist jetzt da jetzt ist er auch ein Element drin ist, das auch bei iTunes anmelden genau der Koran,
Gorn soll ich sagen was da ja das war so ein Ausschnitt aus dem legendären.
Kann man so sagen legendären Interview von Steve Jobs wo er da irgendwie mit irgendjemand so drei Stunden geredet hat das verschwundene wieder aufgetaucht,
weil vorher waren ja nur Teile davon achso.
Ja das kann das Veröffentlichen haben sie dieses verschwundene Tape wiedergefunden und dann gabs das Interview das erste Mal in der vollen Länge zu sehen.
Und da war das mit dem bicycle of the mind.
The computer is the bicycle auf der meint der Computer ist für Weseke.
Einmal genau mm01 das war die Null die nur die erste Folge mit inhalt 1 rausgeworfen dem reload genau.
Nee das ist ja hier schon das ist schon die Sendung das ist ja hier dass er wieder rausgenommen keine Ahnung.
Auch gerade etwas barashka älter als Du dachtest alles nee aber du hast Recht habe ich das gar nicht mehr online.
Haha good you and never change.
Ja das stimmt aber es war ja nicht wirklich so weil du so ein das war nicht nur so ein Platzhalter das war halt einfach nur so ein Verdacht das bemerkenswert dass du das überhaupt gemerkt hast,
na gut der alles die Feier schon immer hier zugegen irgendwie na ja was heißt das jetzt.
10 Jahre modern grau Haare zählen ich meine haben Abendessen vielleicht das dauert die Fehler ich finde Yamaha salopp formuliert.
So ein bisschen was geliefert haben wir ja hier schon also ich mag ja nicht alles toll gewesen sein dass ich unbedingt immer lustig und manchmal auch etwas aber das hat sich dann bisweilen doch abgewechselt mit dem einen oder anderen Highlight,
ontem ehrlich gesagt.
Drehspieß auch mal umdrehen und ich finde jetzt können auch mal die Hörer mal liefern.
Also ich würde mich natürlich extrem freuen über Hinweise auf weiß nicht.
Gute Outtakes so Ausschnitte Momente.
Was ich habe das irgendwie gesagt wichtig ist nicht genug Aufzeichnung und mich auf Ibiza ich bin immer wieder überrascht an an was sich Leute alles so erinnern und das auch teilweise referenziert bekommen also wenn ihr sicherlich nicht jeder.
Da breit ist und widerstandsarchiv durch zu Stiefeln.
Welche Episoden habt ihr im Bilderrahmen zu Hause über dem Kamin stehen genau genau und ihr könnt uns mal fragen.
Stellen also Mama dass du nächsten Sendung Mama das einfach mal.
Freie was ist erlaubt Fragen sind erlaubt alle Fragen sind erlaubt werden vielleicht nicht alle beantwortet auf jeden Fall.
So außer Frankfurt gewünscht.
Na ja vielleicht wäre ich den mir auch was sagen können das weiß man ja vorher nicht ja das stimmt,
deswegen sollte man werde vielleicht auch gar nicht erst Einschreibung jemand fragen heißt ja jetzt irgendwie denkt ihr der Bitcoin Preis wird sich in,
die nächsten vier Wochen über 50000 $ geben das wäre du Fragen die man und Stellen könnte oder was habt ihr euch dabei gedacht als wie in Sendung XY passiert ist,
personne hier offen lassen.
Sich einfach was einfallen und die könnt ihr dann per immer das Hashtag.
Wie funktioniert ganz gut ohne aber also ja weil das könnte alle mitlesen ja und vielleicht auch in einen Fleck schnell zurück Speisen weil hier gab's ganz zu Beginn mal die Idee einen Channel dafür zu haben hier im Pflege.
Slackline Antenne für dieses ask ask.fm.
Die sagen was da gerade nicht das richtige dass du halt so eine korrekt dass man eine Liste erstmal komplett hat.
Ja du weißt wohl nicht rum diskutiert wird und wo das nicht angeht,
müsste er sich jetzt so langweilig auf einen Kanal einigen so ich meine man könnte ich weiß ich kann man Fleck auch auf Hashtags abgraben mit der Integration was ich gerade nicht das weiß ich auch nicht.
Vielleicht habe ich mich nie so richtig ist doch bei dir ab wie kurz an.
Damit der API das weniger zu tun das ist mir so eine Frage dieser dieser dieser integrations und ich habe vorbereitet aber vielleicht mal so generell.
Gute weiß ja nicht von Anfang an dabei.
Nächstes Mal war der nächste Sendung die nächste Sendung schwelgen wir in Erinnerung ich hoffe dass Dennis wieder dabei ist.
Damit auch mal wieder eine Sendung hört.
Rufe zum zum Geburtstag hat mir das jetzt besonders viel bedeutet aber vielleicht zusammen ein schöner Anlass das machen auch irgendwann mal wieder was,
live oder so eure Party haben wir jetzt gerade nicht geplant da muss gleich, ja noch oft Ideen ihr könnt ihr einfach auch mal was vorschlagen.
So aber Tim hoffe du warst Segel nee ich gehe bald segeln aber heute habe ich.
Eine vorbereitende Maßnahme gemacht nämlich meinen überfälliges funkerzeugnis quasi abgelegt funkerzeugnis naja so meine funkerlizenz oder die funkerzeugnis.
Ja nee genau man muss natürlich auch auf dem Boot in der Lage sein sich gehört zu verschaffen und,
genau ich habe eigentlich schon für den letzten Schein diesen Schein gebraucht also ich hätte jetzt auch noch gar nicht so richtig loslegen können trotz day Skipper,
schein ohne diese Radio Lizenz und jetzt habe ich die nachgeholt und dann am Ende des Monats mache ich ja dann.
Hoffentlich meine your master Lizenz und dann darf ich auch mein nachtsegeln und ein bisschen weiter weg von der Küste und so,
gastromaster Yachtmaster das muss ich auch mehr lange so reinfressen ins Hirn dass das,
ja na da heißt danke ja ja ja ja ja ja,
dazu und weil mich ab und zu mal so Leute auch fragen weil ich ja nach der englischen Schule quasi das Segeln lerne was ich auch Nachricht vor,
sehr sehr gut finde wo ich das dann machen würde weil es gibt in Deutschland jetzt nicht so viele Segelschulen die das.
Britische Programm fahren und der weiß wie das nach dem brexit dann aussieht aber es gibt hier in Berlin zumindest eine die nennt sich sailing circle ich suche falsche browser,
ich kann euch mal hier sein sailing circle de ganz easy und dann den Fleck,
kann sich nämlich auch schon mal so ein paar Leute auf Twitter gemeldet und den habe ich das auch schon gesagt die sind da auch,
angekommen und der Michael der da hauptverantwortlich so instruiert der ist auf jeden Fall auch.
Sehr sportlich dabei dass es den ganzen Winter durch gesegelt schon auf verschiedensten Abenteuer Trips und.
Da falls ihr das auch mal machen wollt nach der englischen Schule könnt euch da melden.
Muss der Unterschied zwischen also was gibt's da für unterschiedliche Schulen wenn du sagst du hast unbedingt nach der englischen gesichert also,
der grundlegende Unterschied von den Engländern und im Prozess der Engländer ist einfach dass sie sehr viel Praxis orientierter sind also gerade in Deutschland,
musste irgendwie gefühlte 1000 Seiten lesen bevor du überhaupt mal ein Fuß auf dem Boot sitzen wirklich sehr übertrieben gesagt ne also so schlimm ist es nicht aber es ist wirklich,
sag mal wenn du dich mit Musiktheorie beschäftigt und dann ließe so deutsche Werke zum Thema Musiktheorie dann,
dann rieselt der Staub auf die Augenlider und wird ganzen müde I gespielt hat und dass es so ähnlich,
das dann irgendwie sehr sehr viel Theorie und wirklich sehr ausladend und man muss das auch alles wissen und bevor man hat richtig loslegen kann bei den Engländern die sind sehr viel,
einfach praxisorientierter,
das eine Beispiel was mir dann immer einfällt z.b. ist wenn wie ist heute total heißt Personen über Bord passiert der,
dann.
Sag die deutsche Segelschule oder wie auch immer das Curriculum ja also auf gar keinen Fall den Motor anmachen sondern Segel hinfahren weil man könnte ja die Personen mit dem Propeller von dem Boot schreddern und so weiter ne die Engländer sagen das erste was du machst wenn jemand über Bord fällt in der Mutter nicht anders machst du den Motor an.
Damit du so schnell wie möglich dahin kommst weil in kalten Wasser zählt hat einfach jede Sekunde,
damit du halt nicht erfrierst sozusagen und.
Geteilt also in fast jedem Bereich gibt z.b. wohl der englische Ansatz einfach sehr viel.
Mehr Praxis orientiert als oder,
dieser Inhalt auch man muss nicht alle Verkehrszeichen wissen alle 50.000 bestimmt oder so ne sondern die essentiellen natürlich schon und die Vorfahrtsregeln auch noch aber,
dann also man macht halt bevor man losfährt eson sogenannten patchplan wo man sich überlegt okay wir fahren von da nach da das ist der Kurs da sind die Hindernisse man guckt auf die Karte und dann,
irgendwelche Zeichen drauf sind die man nicht kennt dann gucken wir halt nach na und schreib es dir auf deinen persplan schon mit drauf und was heißt er geht einfach viel mehr um,
Praxiserfahrung sammeln und segeln und ja.
Das heißt so eine Seekarte wenn du die route planst kann man vergleichen mit einer Wanderkarte wo auch in wie drauf steht der assen Zeltplatz da ist irgendwie du dich ins Wasser und dasselbe hast du halt,
wenn sie nur das anhält die Zeichen sind oder da kreuzt sich ein Wanderweg mit ihm von also so eine so eine gleichen hast du dann einfach auf deiner Karte schon direkt drauf bevor du losfährst,
also dann kann eigentlich theoretisch nicht passieren dass du,
irgendwie von wo kommst mit einer Zügen Geschwindigkeit angefahren siehst noch im Augenwinkel das zeichnet so,
lass mal umdrehen ich habe vergessen was ich sollte eigentlich nicht so gerade Gefahrenzone Schifffahrtswege gefährliche Strömung Steine Wrack.
Altes Zeug alles was bekannt ist das ist das schon mit eingezeichneten und dann hast du natürlich noch deine elektronischen Karten heutzutage und.
Die dem natürlich noch mehr Detail Tiefe dann aber schon alleine wenn diese Papierkarte da aus rollst und dann drauf guckst hast du eigentlich alles schon was du wissen musst.
Zeichnest du eigentlich auf der Papierkarte auch deine Rute ein Jahr also sag mal so auf in der Praxis sieht man das nicht dass das Leute tun.
Also gerade so bei Leuten die ein eigenes Boot haben und so rum fand ich nenn mir jetzt keine Namen,
da wird das alles ein bisschen Lachse Hand hat und dann macht es eigentlich hauptsächlich mit GPS und Software.
Aber bei den Engländern ist es also vorgeschrieben dass dass dass du Papierkarten macht dabei haben muss und,
auch lernst natürlich wieder damit umgehst und da planst du deine Route auch noch mit schönen hier Zirkel und.
Bleistift und macht halt auch wirklich ein Personen wo du dir in Stich,
so ab schreibst okay wir fahren jetzt so aus dem Hafen raus dann den Kurs dann bei der Boje den Kurs auf das ändern und dann erstmal soundsoviel mal hin nach Davis,
wir das nächste Ding sehen und irgendwann wenn du dann überall so sein das Land nicht mehr siehst dann.
Der Person auch dementsprechend etwas weniger Rally Beifahrer,
in in Küstennähe wir haben es ja in England gemacht da sind wir diverse Male ohne GPS Hilfe sagen gefallen also nur mit.
Was ist ein Bastard und alles in Küstennähe da sind halt viele Bojen und Leuchttürme und so mit dem Kompass sozusagen teilen und dann gucken wir sind jetzt irgendwie 140° zu diesem,
Leuchtturm das heißt wir müssen jetzt immer noch irgendein landmark sehen da auch noch die Person in der macht halt auch so wirklich diesen,
nur zwei Linien auf die Haare dann kannst du genau dadurch halt deine Position ermitteln dass du irgendwie weiß wo du in etwa bist und diesen ganzen Kram.
Also ich meine die sagen halt auch in ihren Lehrmaterial ja ist zwar alles gut und schön jetzt gibt's GPS und es gibt GLONASS und bald gibt Galileo oder gibt's schon keine Ahnung.
Aber was ist wenn das Gerät jetzt also Stromausfall und das geht gar nichts mehr an und dann.
Ja hast du trotzdem deinen dividend dann musst du halt trotzdem muss und trotzdem noch wissen wie es mit anderen Mitteln geht aber letztendlich hatte ich glaube ich auch schon mal gesagt wenn du mit,
sechs Leuten fährst hast du ungefähr 12 Uhr GPS-Geräte an Bord mit Batterie und die Chance dass du wirklich gar nichts mehr empfängt ist dann schon relativ gering,
aber nichtsdestotrotz kann natürlich auch sein dass irgendein Ionensturm kommen und alle Satelliten ausfallen oder was auch immer und dann musst du wenn nur z.b. in your master oceanmaster machst du auch Astronavigation Sextant und so,
Master offshore.
Und das ist aber immer noch sozusagen nah genug dran als dass man glaube ich da noch keine Astronavigation brauch.
Musst du dann eigentlich auch also bei dem Panamakanal bin ich halt jetzt schon das zweite Mal da dran wir sind nach dem so eigentlich will ich dann mal gern,
durch Chef antworten muss man eigentlich auch dann speziell für so Schleusen noch einen Kurs machen oder weißt du das in der Regel ein weißt du also.
Ist jetzt noch nicht vorgekommen dass das Material III das ist meistens du kriegst halt für irgendein Segelgebiet wo du unterwegs bist halt sogenannte heilit Box oder.
Pilots edge,
books war halt so für alle möglichen wichtigen Sachen im Prinzip beschrieben ist wie das Verfahren ist auf welchem Kanal du die anfangsvideo dich anmeldest an welcher Seite du mit deinem kleinen Boot anlegen musst und so weiter das heißt für solche Sachen,
hast du denn noch zusätzliche Lektüre die das mit angibt und ja nee so schlau sind jetzt nicht so bisher.
Behandelt worden interessiert war eben da war auch so dieses du hast einen Segelboot gehabt und,
hinter ihm in der Schleuse stand inhalt der fette Container und dann erstmal so gesehen so das Containerschiff in Panama Max Maas hoffentlich bin halt auch so groß wie nie schiffsschleusen nur vom Pappel,
also in der großen Schleuse weiß ich jetzt auch noch nicht aber.
Ab und zu begegnen wir einen großen Containerschiffen also als wir einmal in Lissabon waren da war das weltgrößte Containerschiff direkt am Hafen Ausgang festgemacht und dann fährst du da halt so ne und dann merkst dann komm hier sowie die,
tut Signal so,
tut das schallende Geräusch von dem Ding dass das jetzt loswerden und dann siehst dann habe ich dieses Hochhaus sich anfängt so zu bewegen und dann du mit deiner kleinen Nussschale schnell weg,
oder in den Bergen waren wir auch einmal und da haben sich so diese Kreuzfahrtschiffe die Klinke in die Hand und dann musst du eben auch irgendwo mit deinem kleinen Bötchen so dazwischen fahren dass du also,
ist es nicht eng oder so aber die machen ja auch schon Wellen und halt mit denen ja,
auf dem Meer Meer Welle,
okay also es ist einfach nur von den Größenverhältnissen bisweilen etwas verspüren.
Nee aber das ist eigentlich auch schon der kleine Segel Beitrag ja segelt will da.
Ich finde das englische Programm wirklich sehr gut und vor allen Dingen der funkerkurs der war ganz cool weil die haben Software.
Die Engländer also ist auch alles ja nicht nur coole Bücher also wirklich schön illustriert und didaktisch gut aufgearbeitet die haben Software und zwar,
im iOS Store im Mac Store Mac App Store von der AWO the Royal Yachting association,
wurde z.b. auch für den funkerkurs nicht nur das Material irgendwie noch mal zu dem Buch aufbereite bekommst dann kriegst halt auch ein Funkgerät Simulator der dann,
sogar und das ist jetzt hier für die Audio Nazi da Spezialist historium geht ja so Software die,
immer davon ausgeht dass das Mikrofon auf Input 1 ist oder Input 1 und 2.
Und es ignoriert dann diese Software.
Oder kommt überhaupt nicht damit klar wenn das nicht System Input ist und so weiter nur eines mal bei der Software tatsächlich so dass sie mit meinem Audio-Interface und mit einem angeschlossenen Kondensatormikrofone irgendwie so richtig meine Funksprüche entgegennehmen konnte,
weiß nicht seit wann das ja noch mit Spracherkennung gecheckt haben ob alles stimmt.
Aber das Funkgerät muss das halt einschalten richtig die Sensitivität einschalten und die Kanäle wählen und so weiter und der hat ja auch gesagt wenn eine Ansage schon also auf jeden Fall viel zu kurz war und,
das fand ich wird,
wirklich sehr sehr cool dass die einfach nicht nur eben gesagt diese coolen Bücher haben sondern auch digital einfach vorne am Start und nicht dachte schon so hat muss ich mir jetzt nämlich ein Flash Player installieren also weißt du ich wusste nicht wie das sein wird und dann,
nehir Mac App Store iOS Store Google Play Store bitteschön und Respekt.
Im Chat wird gerade noch gefragt ob du Funk morgen oder nur Sprechfunk hat das wird nicht mehr gemacht das ist Vergangenheit schon,
relativ lange auch in der Marine wird das nicht mehr gemacht also es wird jetzt nur noch gefunkt oder digital gefunkt.
Dessertschale wieso kannst du mal außen,
oder nicht oder was mehr gelernt aber ich finde es immer gut wenn es Leute gibt die solche Kulturtechniken auch noch weiter tragen können als kleine betreiben ist auch eine Kulturtechnik gewesen irgendwann mal,
Fahrzeugen,
der Motor bitte reichlich ist das aushändigen mein Opa hatte so eine Tisch Dampfmaschine hattet ihr vielleicht auch so wo man dann auch so irgendwelche Sachen mit zum Relief Lied never also Wahrheit keine Ahnung.
Und die dann immer mal an zu werfen auf jeden Fall ein echtes Highlight und dann Summe zum Gummiriemen irgendwelche anderen Sachen damit irgendwie noch zu betreiben.
Das hätte ich tatsächlich ich frage mich auch wo die ist sie hätte ich für Dich sehr sehr sehr sehr gerne noch mal so einfach als.
Wenn Jungs Besitzer Dampfmaschine,
Dampfwalze na also du wirst das Ding an und dann bewegt es sich aus auch also fahren wäre übertrieben aber es.
Bewegt sich aber ja bei Mäusen gesagt da hört der Spaß auf aber ja ich habe ja auch nie irgendwo Tele,
Graf achso auf Deutsch oder auch gerne mal irgendwie so,
wechselbügel zwischen am Technikmuseum oder sowas gemacht wird jetzt halt nur noch in Band auf dem Kongress Daten der schon gelernt.
Du kannst auch sterben wird es nicht aber zu praktisch.
Morsen also nicht morgen so wie es früher mal gemacht wurde sollen so als Codierung also so als wäre ich die Einzige.
Verbreitete nähere.
Tennis ATP Turniere schon alles falsch erzählt aber ist die einzige ternera codierungs Form die irgendwie nennenswerte Verbreitung hat.
Oder wenig unsicher Tanja.
Also dreh genau kurz Pause.
Gibt es zwei verschiedene Pausenlänge oder so eine Pause zwischen den Zeichen nicht als Teil.
Nee das ist mir so Takt das ist mir so die Pause wird ja durch erst durch den Tag zu der Pause dann hast du nur drei Zeichen.
Kurz lang und Pause genau 100 von daher ist es Isys einzige populäre tendiere Codierungsverfahren.
Sollen wir jetzt mindestens nix einfallen alles andere ist.
Ja noch für wertiger also so Flaggenalphabet und so weiter bin ich noch in Neuss.
Absicht in der Anfangszeit der Computer auch noch so ein paar ternera ernähre ja ja mit ternera Logik.
Soll das für ein Zustand ich sehe weiß ich nicht 20 oder so naja plusminus und kein Strom.
Nicht dass ich wüsste mir war so nachher vielleicht egal was ist gehabt 9 Bit Computer.
Nenne mich zu Mittag oder auch gerne mit wie nennt man das dann tritt nein weiß nicht verlier halt na ja egal.
Tri-state tri-state.
Manchester Code der hat aber jetzt nichts mit Turnier akontierung zu tun erstmal,
whatever whatever jemand fragt ob es nicht primär heißen sollte,
ja das kann man fordern aber es heißt,
brauche ich das,
also ich weiß auch nicht warum das so ist es auch externe kurze zwischen reupold haben ja die vier ist das.
Polizei ich habe nicht weiter im TV gucken die blinkt auch und sie.
Connected auch das auch noch aus bei Gerät ich muss mich korrigieren tanzen auf der Wikipedia-Seite als ternär auch drinne.
Bezeichnet man in der Chemie gibt es tendiere Verbindung in der Logik gibt's dreiwertige Logik.
Ja und Mathe ein Stellenwertsystem zur Basis 3 siehe ternär System genau oder mal was für ternär Systeme so am Start sind.
Bitte bitte das ist ja alles rein mathematisch mathematisch.
Sie schon wieder steht hier nicht first modern electronic ternary Computer wehtun US Bild 1958 in das verwirrt,
Union the Moscow State University bei Nicolai Blusentop.
Krass die Russen Lauer electricity consumption and production cost haha musst du mal,
muss mal noch so das ist das geile Link trockenen sowieso wieder viel zu wenig Links hier in Wikipedia ternary Computer du sollst mir das nicht sagen sollst das lag reinschmeißen ich bin nicht alleine die Championsleague überhaupt erst angeklickt achso verstehe,
Kristalle züchten,
herrlicher Flotte hier alles durcheinander steht drauf mir auf der Seite die ich gerade aufgerufen habe,
ich habe das nicht soweit gelesen keine Termine,
Ziffer wird auch als bezeichnet,
brexit traxlmayr,
ja ich finde das ja immer in meinem muss ja sagen das ich find ja dieses dieses diese Zahlensysteme Thema finde ich ja irgendwie.
Finde eigentlich immer wieder sehr ergiebig weiß nicht was hier schon aber Zahlensystem unterhalten habe ich glaube so in der Form nicht ne ich habe das irgendwann mal.
Entschuldige auch ein Stück.
Citybutler so ist richtig die kommt ihr einfach immer mit so gesunden Zeug wie wird irgendwann nicht mehr so viel.
Dummes Zeug erzählen ich hoffe es ist bestimmt gesünder als abends Bier zu trinken das macht eine Plauze.
Was soll mir schon eine Platte gesehen texteinleitung Pulli,
weniger deutlich weniger Plaut sich als gewisse andere Teilnehmer in diesem Etablissement,
hast du gerade LED die dicken an Teilnehmerinnen.
Ja soviel dazu.
Ich sehe die Person gerade nach Hause finden wann genau das mit dem Magen aufgehört hat Kiel steht nur dass zum 1. Februar 1999 das mausen an Bedeutung verloren.
Weil der nämlich das weltweite sehen und Unsicherheit Funksystemen GMDSS an den Start ging und das Maß.
Weiß dass das noch bis in die 2000er genutzt wurde vom Militär und sauber da wird es nicht mehr mittlerweile verwendet.
Vermisst an der Stelle noch mal was gerade bei Zahlensystem oder war ich bei Zahlensystem waren wir und ihr euch über.
Fang und 2. unterhalten ab wollte ich noch mal einen Podcast plagen wo ich zu Gast bin,
und ich werde ja sehr nette ich werde ja es wird ja sehr selten eingeladen.
Sind wir so schlimm willst doch die Kontrollverlust könnte ich nicht ertragen.
Nee ich war mal zu Gast bei Fiona.
Ja leider ihren Podcast nicht fortgeführt hat aber der bis dahin eigentlich ganz cool war nur der thermasol diesen ich lerne alles gestartet als Podcast gestartet.
Und da habe ich mich mit ihr mal unterhalten uns Wasser befreien muss ich sagen mal in dieser Antworter Rolle zu sein und habe mal ich habe mal digital erklärt.
Also so.
Von ganz von Anfang an also so nicht über digitales geredet sondern ist ja wohl auch schon wieder Rudi redest heraus ist eine Feststellung von mir das eigentlich die meisten Leute und zwar einschließlich der.
Totalen top Nerds also würde ich auch Leute die völlig alles drauf haben programmieren alles ja,
die eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur ins Licht starren,
Offenbach V behindert sind dann werden wir drauf ankommt die Basics zu erklären vollkommen scheitern,
weil dass ich dann auch so wie wir wie das halt immer so ist bei Leuten die irgendwie über irgendetwas wissen ja dann irgendwann ist so gut wussten dass sie dann nicht mehr verstanden haben was andere eigentlich nicht verstehen,
das für Gitarristen die guten Gitarristen können keine Gitarrenstimme warum auch immer ja können die guten Gitarristen an den Leuten Gitarre spielen beibringen.
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht wahrscheinlich können Sie vor allem nicht erklären warum die Gitarre das tut was sie tut wenn Sie sie benutzen wie auch immer das führt jetzt zu weit nur,
ich habe halt irgendwann mal an diesem Wort fest gemacht weil ich dann halt einfach am angefangen habe heute zu fragen was digital eigentlich heißt,
also was es wirklich heißt und es weiß gefühlt niemand und ich habe vielleicht so von 100 Leuten.
Bestenfalls was meinst du denn damit was leid was heißt was was bedeutet das Wort digital bei der Lage weiße kitos lateinisch der Finger.
Body ist willkommen bei den Versand ja aber was bedeutet es na ja absehbar mit mit dem Finger sehr schön.
Check this country continuum sondern eben abziehen deswegen bist du deswegen bist du ja hier auch im Team.
Richard Lichtblicke aber nur die schönsten und besten haben auch immer die Frage stellen Duden digital besser ist.
Also war jetzt alles mit der digitalen ne ja und dann oder warum auch nicht weil das besser ist.
Besser so muss er besser sein reale Freunde,
ja die digitale klasse warte und wenn man die digital Klasse fragt was Digitalis Digitalis,
na ja auf jeden Fall wer sitzt da mal Lust hat es genau erklärt zu bekommen oder vielleicht auch jemand anderen mal,
Susanne the Full Monty zugeben also es geht es nicht nur um digitales geht auch Versorgung Zahlensysteme Unterschied zwischen zahlen und Ziffern und Wertigkeiten und der da dran hängt,
dass das Prinzip dass man Shellac mit ihm machen.
Irgendwann hatte ich das auch schon mal ich weiß nicht ob es schon schon mal eine Freakshow erzählt hatte aber ich hatte ja auch mal so einen kleinen Vortrag irgendwo gehalten,
Unwohlsein mein ganzen Kurs nicht man Semester halte so einmal eine halbe Stunde zusammen gedampft habt ihr armen Zuhörer ging es auch kurz auf das Thema digital und dann meinte ein aus dem Publikum,
was ich dann folgerichtig dann auch mit aufgenommen habe wer hat dann so gemeint ja genau das mit dem Silber und so weiter und selbst eine Uhr.
Eine analoge Uhr ist im Prinzip digital weil da ja quasi fest eingehämmert Intervalle sind ne die Unruhe die Zahnräder Tic Tac 60 Sekunden das ist alles Silber und die einzig analoge Uhr,
ist die Sonne nur eine Wasseruhr ist vielleicht auch noch,
ist könnte man auch als analog bezeichnen wenn du nicht argumentieren dass man die Wassermoleküle abzählen kann oder Designer aber wir wissen eine Wasseruhr die Zeit,
was ist ein Eimer mit einem Loch in der Pfütze Wasser ein.
Und nach einer bestimmten Zeit ist der leer und dann kannst du eine Skala an den Eimer innen machen und kannst aber dann nach einer gewissen Zeit ablesen wie viel Zeit vergangen ist dadurch dass da eine konstante Menge an Wasser raus fließt du haben die in der Artikel was Zeit gemessen,
wenn sie keine Sanduhr hat.
Na ja auf jeden Fall bei der Sonnenuhr kann man sich das halt auch noch mal sehr schön vorstellen weil das dann einfach nur so ein wandernder Schatten ist gerade die Unruh dieses Ding was immer klick klack,
backmatten.
Und dann kann man dass ich die nächste Frage stellen und wie ist es mit den Herzschlag ist der analog oder digital weil zählen kann man ihn war das jetzt eine.
Bei der Herzschlag ist ja schon eine Abstraktion ist ja sozusagen eine Betrachtung Rechtsaußen die eben abstrahiert und damit eben digitalisiert und damit ist es halt selber.
Das heißt aber nicht dass alle Vorgehen der Ansicht dazu beitragen zählbar sind,
aber es halt auch so eine schöne kleine Meter Frage wo dann erstmal so die Hirne kurzer gilt erstmal garnichts Digitalis.
So so lange bis intelligenzspiel kommen.
Ja eigentlich ist es mit der zelba kalt ja auch eine Abstraktion das ist das ist die.
Abspielen heraus dass du weißt wo etwas anfängt und wo etwas aufhört.
Weil sonst kannst du ja nicht trennen.
Ja das hat dir das Trennen von denen das macht etwas erzählen muss er wissen wo ein Apfel anfängt und wurde Apfel aufhört damit und Apfel zählen kannst.
So und und und dass er das was die in diesem das auch keine Intelligenz die nur der Mensch hat sich nur nur nur wo es beim Menschen sind halt total.
Total Kurs.
Habe ich auch immer noch so einen. Dann ich guck mal gerade ob ich das finde hier genau.
Wie kann ich denn das mal kurz als Bild hier rausholen und Mama wann Screenshot davon und Chips in den Chat,
weil nämlich wenn es dann um digital geht und wie Computer so funktionieren dann versuche ich das dann auch irgendwie mit der eins unter Null und Strom an und Strom aus und warum bist du überhaupt binär und nicht dezimal und so weiter,
weil es gab es ja auch mal dezimal Computer als was so los ging und dann zeige ich dir immer so ein Bildchen.
Mal sehen ob es Herzchen slack ankommt hat ihn mal Computer genau nehme ich hier so,
wovon ist das jetzt ein Bild vom Oszilloskop genau das jetzt ein Bild vom Oszilloskop und zwar wenn man Strom an und Strom ausschaltet weil abstrakt in so Büchern kriegt man dann so wenn man das über die Zeit plotten also,
dann ist er so Rechtecke und gerade Kanten und so weiter aber man dann mal nachguckt je schneller man Strom an und Strom ausschalte desto mehr schwingt dieses Signal halt nach und Klingel sozusagen sagt man ja auf doch Holzstange,
und dann ist halt irgendwann wenn man sozusagen zehn unterschiedliche Zustände feststellen wollen würde dann deshalb,
bei einigen dieser Schwingungen nicht klar ja ist das jetzt eine 3 oder ist das eine 4 oder was auch immer und deswegen,
der Signal-Rauschabstand dann am Ende des Tages kommt man ja auch so auf diese Theesener ja.
Auch jetzt auch der Computer ist am Ende digital-analog also geht er immer noch durch so,
analoges Medium und das rauscht und das hat neues und da geht er flippen die Bits und so weiter was du da siehst ist aber kein Rauschen sondern das liegt daran dass dein Kanal Bandbreite hat,
und die oberste Frequenz die noch durchkommt die siehst du ja hier als Schwingung.
Ja also das ist jetzt nicht neues das ist einfach dieses Schwingverhalten von genau Schaltkreisen genau erzeugt ja Neuss,
na in SSO nachlesen des Signals ist es für dich halt dann in der Interpretation des Signals ist das dann halt.
Nein aber das ist nicht neues einfach nur eine Störung und es ist nur neues neues und das ist einfach mal die habe ich noch die entsteht dadurch dass der das die Bandbreite im Kanal beschränkt ist.
Also.
Da ist quasi Tiefpassfilter drauf und der Tiefpassfilter führt dazu dass die klaren Kanten von einem Rechteck wenn es denn eingebe im Frequenzbereich abgeschnitten wird und dann schwingt das so nach.
Aber das hat nichts mit Rauschen Ansicht zu tun,
das wiederum reinkommt dadurch dass du analoge Bauteil hast ja das habe ich auch gar nicht behauptet das ist eine weitere Komponente die deine theoretischen Signale halt alle verunreinigt und am Ende,
ist ebend,
mich alles 1 und 0 manchmal.
S2 digital aber es geht auch durch analog und dann ist man wieder in der Hand. I aber der Clou ist halt eben man kann zählen und,
wenn dann irgendwie bis verloren gehen dann weiß man es halt und das ist das schöne dabei aber wie soll ich das als zuschulden alles für den alten außerdem 0,
dieser Effekt mit der Schwingung führt übrigens dazu dass deine Kanal Bandbreite die Obergrenze der maximal zu senden.
Möglichen zusenden im Zeichen angibt.
Was wie wo dieses Schwinger in dieses schwingen wegen dem begrenzten analysis schwingen und auf den Bildschirm zeigt sagt das ja der 100% der Hörer nicht.
Scheiße ja so ist das der Effekt der Effekt dass du wenn du ein Tiefpassfilter hast dein Rechteck zu einem zu einer Schwingung.
Ja Nuggets beträgt wir haben jetzt gerade die ganze Zeit über dieses Bild Geräte und jetzt willst du dass ich das erkläre mache ich jetzt nicht wusste auch gar nicht weil ich meinte das auch neues auch,
Anas aber das führt jetzt vielleicht zu weit,
Ja Nein scheiße ich das weiterhin,
die die Kanal begrenzen der Schwingung die du da siehst die führt dazu dass ein Kanal ner gewissen Bandbreite eine maximal Anzahl von Zeichen erlaubt.
So und der neues von dem du sprichst also das Rauschen das fremd Rauschen was du auf dem Kanal hast führt dazu dass du die Anzahl der unterschiedlichen unterscheidbaren Zeichen abnimmt.
Ja also bei einem bei einem bei einem,
idealen Kanal könntest du theoretisch auch unendlich viele Zeichen voneinander unterscheiden weil du jeden einzelnen Spannungswert an jeder einzelnen Stelle voneinander unterscheiden kannst aber sobald du da rauschen drauf hast also,
stochastische Effekte die durch.
Alles mögliche ausgelöst werden genau verschwimmen ineinander so dass du halt was ich nicht vier oder,
8 oder weiß ich nicht keine Ahnung mein Kind ist von den ganz alten Modems die hat auf einer schlechten Leitung nicht so eine Datenrate hatten weil die so stark geraucht hat,
dass man hinterher also das Modem nicht so viele Zeichen voneinander nehmen.
Der Moden.
Bitte vermeiden.
Ich hatte das vergessen aber ich habe nicht behauptet dass man der Mode sagen soll,
weißt du was sagen,
ja das ist meine das ist jetzt.
Was Leute sagen der Blog das Blog deshalb ist durchgesessen das blockiert.
Also die wenigen nicht also wir sagen dass sie noch Leute der Blogger.
Wetter Wertach.
Wann geht die Welt unter hier ne,
Dschungel der angeblich ist dass das Wort was irgendwie alle Dschungel Dschungel Dschungel.
Adidas,
ja na ja also ja wie gesagt ist es mit alles eins ist alles ist eins außer der Null das ist auch tatsächlich einer meiner absoluten Lieblings,
du kannst es auch dieses Bild schon wieder minimieren damit Evelyn restlichen ca genau da war doch noch was irgendwas hast du weniger gezappelt.
Ach ja.
So etwas durcheinander Themen geil die wir nicht hatten aber wollte noch was bringen,
ich musste erstmal als hier also ich habe irgendwann leider ausgeschalten weil ausgegangen und,
ganz klar und hat noch ein bisschen geguckt so hier zum Aladin friere halt auch.
Erwärmt und muss mich kurz an meine Signalverarbeitung Vorlesung wieder erinnern das also ich habe.
Medizininformatik Schönheit auch biosignalverarbeitung gehabt aber das war leider nicht so tiefgreifend wie es vielleicht irgendwie interessant gewesen wäre.
Aber mit viel mit Matlab gearbeitet und ebenso irgendwelche Filter angewendet auf Signale um 7 zu glätten tool.
Bis auf dass ich weiß nicht wie sie voll ist und das ist halt nicht so cool aber jetzt dein Thema ne.
Ich habe also jetzt hasse ich gesammelt.
Nur hier Podcast Empfehlung und Software Empfehlung,
nee das eine ist ja sag mir mal bitte was du gerade Software Empfehlung gesagt ich fand es nur wunderschön ich weiß garnicht wie es in meinen Feed gespült kam dass es dass ich jemand die Mühe gemacht hat.
Venen in den Browser zurück.
Bekommen und noch ein bisschen nostalgische also ich die irgendeine der LTP Folgen hörten und sie ICQ sagten und ich insgeheim meine Nummer vor mir her brabbelt 5646 29308 1969,
oder sonst mich lange.
Weiß ich nicht manchmal ist es nicht mehr ich müsste mal gucken ob ich dieses Passwort auch noch dazu gecovert bekomme ich überhaupt noch die nächste Frage und ich glaube ich konnte in meinem artium ICQ auch.
S50 561146 genau das war meine Nummer ich hatte nämlich eine 8-stellige.
Nicht immer das Glück mit Nummern Telefonnummern ICQ Nummern dass ich so.
Repetitive Sachen habe oder Sachen die sich verändern secure kostet mittlerweile gehört mittlerweile den Russen Mail.ru group.
Aber bei dir Böses camspam herkommt immer noch.
Hattet ihr denn schon mehrfach immer noch ICQ ist nicht zu fassen wie dafür muss man Geld bezahlen ich weiß nicht aber dafür was bezahlen muss aber es gibt es noch.
Jemand hat dafür Geld bezahlt zu kaufen es kommt ja aus Israel 2000.
Für alle die Leute dieses gegründet haben das war noch nie zu teilen Heldentat abhalten in Israel was ist also das erste große Internet Ding was Andi aus Israel auch kam.
Und das sogar mein Passwort noch in der keychain aber Winamp gibt es im Browser sagst du ja,
Jäger ich kann das einfach also ich weiß nicht ob du mich wieder Sonntag Holding in braun kaputt gespielt mit dem ersten Klick Problem.
Manz was immer sowieso ein Chrome starten aber irgendwann nicht mehr so gut gewesen.
Für ihre neue Internet Explorer deswegen funktionieren da viele Sachen nicht die Absicht nur entschieden andere Sachen zu unterstützen als Google.
Firefox ja das stimmt der Wind ein bisschen bisschen kaputt so schön ist dieses.
Dieses Bild sein ich weiß noch wie sehr ich halt Wilhelms geliebt habe im Vergleich zu halt jetzt iTunes.
Na ja ich muss sagen es war nicht ganz so also bin im war damals das einzige was geil wäre alles besser Google und dann kam irgendwann die ersten Version von iTunes raus oder wie heißt es doch gleich jamplay oder Soundplayer oder wie ist das früher,
Countdown Sound denn sowas und ich fand es tatsächlich instantan geiler als Winamp aber,
bis dahin und dann als wenn iPhone scheiße war bestimmt cool,
McCann ich hatte noch irgendwie Mac gewechselt bin aber an den erinner ich mich nicht mehr so richtig warum ich das cooler finde als jetzt z.b. iTunes ist dass du halt Musik einfach reinziehen konntest,
von irgendeinem Stick oder keine Ahnung und es hat es halt erstmal einfach abgespielt ohne es irgendwohin synchronisieren und speichern zu wollen.
Und es war so einfach schön kann ich einfach ich weiß nicht auf jeden Fall auch lange Zeit benutze ich noch halt.
Windows Mate genau also früher als Mann wie Huckel das auch so schön gesagt dass ich noch nichts leisten konnte er will nur dich an dazu jetzt eine Verbindung zu haben.
Ich find's halt nicht also ich habe jetzt auch eine mal nicht.
Achso du hättest sie gerne nicht gehabt also ich hatte keine zu Winamp eigentlich weil ich diese ganzen Windows Welt ja mich.
Komplett entzogen hast ja ich habe in meinem Leben glaube ich ein Programm mal gestartet auf Windows.
Also außer dass ich mal auf Windows Computer so browser oder sowas gestartet aber wieso das einzige Programm was ich benutzt habe.
Wo ich auch selber irgendwas damit gemacht habe das war page Maker auf Windows 10 das war das einzige Programm Visual Studio.
Jacke Visual Studio 7 Windows 3.1 oder Windows 95 oder XP.
Jemals für irgendwas benutzt man nach den stimmt das war.
Also 31 habe ich auch nicht im produktiven Einsatz gehabt 95 auch nicht 98 bei mir ging das mit Windows Windows NT 4.0 los.
Nach zwei Tagen installieren lief der Rechner dann auch.
Der arbeitet jetzt gerade meine Verdrängung perfekt aber ich glaube ich habe nie.
Nicht umkippen nur in einem einzigen Programm jemals unter Windows auch eine Datei abgespeichert mit eigenem gehalten seit 1990 ja ich hätte auch gerne vermieten gehabt aber wie gesagt das.
Glück hatte ich leider nicht aber die Entwickler von Winamp wie die das programmiert haben.
Könnt ihr die Leute die Reaper machen dies hoffe die gerade diesen Podcast aufnehmen war das ja auch nicht so dass Apple übernimmt damals den Kampf angesagt hatte auch mit iTunes Garbsen ich auch irgendwas wo.
Kann ich mich dann habe ich noch ein anderes Programm.
Von einer anderen Bruder Diät aber es gibt eine Geschichte des sowie die Wilhelmplatz bei Steve Jobs aufgetaucht sind und erinnere dich die ganze Zeit erzählt hat sie einpacken können aber ich weiß ja,
naja letztenendes hat er recht gehabt,
ja warum sollte er sie warum sollte er darauf Zeit vergeuden Leuten zusammen das sieht keine Chance mehr also das ist irgendwie das bei mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Ja vielleicht wollten sie ihm irgendwas verkaufen das kann wiederum sein woran er gesagt hat also wenn ihr hier habt damit könnt ihr einpacken,
das kann ich mir bei Steve Jobs sogar ziemlich gut angefangen hatte dieses Interface an wenn du das einem Steve Jobs unter die Nase hält sagt er dir natürlich du kannst mich wunderbar,
keine keine inhalt 13! Preis kommst du da gar nicht mehr durch die Tür.
Also wann wurde es gemacht 1997 ging das mit Winamp los war da nicht noch also wann ist Ostern überhaupt,
na das war doch der da gabs sonst zaunschirm und iTunes gab's auch das schon wo ist denn na ja,
next wurde gekauft Ende 97 kam Juli 98 raus wann kam Winamp 97 April,
real Garbsen Skorpion ist es auf einmal sagen muss dass das erste Soundchips schon extrem.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen sich auch ja also eine andere Interpretation dieses dieser Idee besser.
Wilhelm war damals schon einfach ein cooler audioplay kann man schon so sagen hatte auch gleich diese Audio wieso visualizations und Nerven Kram.
Ja wenn auch wenn gerade Space Night nicht lief ja High Five an alle Hörer die damals schon espacenet geguckt haben.
Wird es Sonnenschein war nie schlimm ich mein das war für damalige.
Ja ich esse war lag im Lack voll im Trend alle voll im Trend ja jetzt gibt es auf jeden Fall in Brause.
Pseudo nach klicken kann man damit auch Musik abspielen oder,
man kann das würde mal lol sagt er kann dann nicht wir warten jetzt auf Sound Sound MGs,
nein nein ich warte darauf nichts verschwendet nicht eure Lebenszeiten,
der Chat weißt du wie sich Mülleimer daraufhin der QuickTime Player ja besser aussah,
er hatte halt nicht dieses Playlist Konzeptes da da stand ja irgendwie komischerweise immer viele drauf.
Was ich auch nie so ja aber auch Zeiten wurde wo der QuickTime Player richtig scheiße aussah das muss man einfach mal sagen ja jetzt gerade,
nee aber auch kannst du nicht nach Hilden oder hätte als er als er diese Schublade hatte wo man da so die Filialen liegen konnte und so das war doch ganz schlimm ja ja ja diverse,
also ich bin auch Quicktime-Player ist wirklich kein,
Qualitätsprodukt ein Beispiel für da lief immer alles richtig geil in Sachen User-Interface und experience also es gab dort aber das Tool,
Valley also QuickTime Player ist völlig unterschätzt was du mit dem Ding machen konntest das konnte so halt einfach mit nicht auf dem Planeten machen.
Ich meinte QuickTime Player Wand vollständiges Videoschnittprogramm.
Du kannst ja fast vollständig Vanessa vollständig indem du vollständig etwas schneiden konntest du konntest erhalten Filme markieren in of copy paced machen copy paced mit Video das ging das schon mal.
390 das ging dann zehn Jahre lang nirgendswo.
Und dann kam der Rest der Welt langsam mal so zum Erwachen aber das war einfach seiner Zeit so weit voraus wie nur irgendwas war aber halt kein geile audio player so vermehrt Audioplayer war das natürlich nicht gedacht,
aber der Player aber ich war gut aber ich weiß nicht was findest du jetzt am aktuellen,
QuickTime Player schlimm das ist falsch wieso in 98% der alten funktioniert nicht mehr hat ja aber ich mein vom Aussehen her es ist ein Fenster das ein Video drin also sehen.
User interface nicht aussehen user interface ist wie es funktioniert ja ja ist ein Fenster und dann ist es ja auch der Player nicht,
Territorium video editing Workstation.
Ja sorry ich habe einen anderen Anspruch ich will halt auch mal schnell irgendwie was brauchbar mit in und outpoint versehen und drinnen können und so weiter damit der Player für mich auch richtig funktioniert ja damit schneidest du ja auch keine Platten.
Plattenspieler ist er ja wohl auch nicht der Maßstab Player Scheißdreck,
ich will einfach das geilste Tool und sorry dann muss einfach mehr ja aber nicht unter dem Namen na ja das denn aber war vielleicht nicht optimal LASK Linz,
wollen wir eigentlich achso eigentlich Musik mp3.
Na ist ja warum muss man die irgendwie hinten an die URL dann dranhängen oder wie macht man,
hier wird gerade im Chat auf irgendwas hingewiesen ihr habt doch echt so den Arsch auf meine Wikipedia ist echt nicht zu fassen.
Jetzt schlagen Sie vor den Artikel über die gulaschprogrammiernacht zu löschen.
Wird es aber wissen ob noch wo oben und unten ist Relevanz Zweifel.
Vanessa irgendjemand hat immer Relevanz zeige sich meine Mutter nicht da dran aber ich wollte die Gelegenheit nutzen vielleicht auf diese Veranstaltung hinzuweisen weil die ist ja im Mai und.
Da kann man dann vielleicht auch mal,
die Relevanz Diskussion erstell auch etwas unterfüttern dann habt ihr ein Medienprodukt eine Medienproduktion auf der die Relevanz hingewiesen wird zwar keine Zeitung.
Aber wir sind ja da wir haben ja so dieses Mal auf unter meiner linken.
Nur warum ist das relevant gib en das halt so eine Veranstaltung aus dem Club umfällt und zwar konkret aus Karlsruhe.
Machte Intropia eV und ist jetzt auch schon seit 2002 Darmstadt.
Das schonmal echt eine Heritage ich war jetzt schon ein paar Jahre nicht mehr da Plan allerdings dieses Jahr dann endlich mal da zu sein,
wenn ich mal wach das Problem gelöst bekomme wann ist das,
das ist im Mai das war lange Zeit immer über Pfingsten diesmal nicht die GPN 18 bis 13. Mai.
Sieht aus dieses Christi Himmelfahrt,
von Christi Himmelfahrt bis Muttertag Vatertag bis Muttertag sozusagen und findet im Zentrum ZKM statt also Kunst und Medientechnologie.
Karlsruhe und David nackt so.
Ja das liest das irgendwie ne ne ne ne ne korrekte Veranstaltung wie es halt einfach seit Ewigkeiten gibt uns.
Wie kann Gulasch nicht relevanter hat man dann irgendwie ja wahrscheinlich haben sich Leute gedacht dass das kann doch nicht der richtige Name sein das ist halt ich weiß nicht wie das entstanden ist aber das war halt ich habe die hat nur wie eine Gulaschkanone da am Start.
Und man wollte sich halt zum Programmieren treffen so sorry und das war's dann und dann haben sie den Halt GPN genannt so und wie das eben so ist mit solchen nachdem wie die macht dann so schnell nicht wieder los und,
ja deswegen heißt es Gulasch vor mir nach das ist das einfach,
für den Namen durchaus cool weil er irgendwie senden gewöhnliches ist Essen super super super Name sowas also das ist das ist top.
Top Qualität 1a verwechslungsgefahr = 0 ja besser als dieser ganze mobile media world.
Convention knas ich meine damit 83 und alle bekloppt sind und wo nur du,
sich irgendwie Kopf und Kragen reden also nicht alle keine Ahnung haben doch aus Aral,
würde einfach mal,
darf ich das gut hatte mal hin bei Muttern auch genau weiß,
zolpidem Dichte in dieser Sendung,
Kletterhilfe.
Also im Arbeitsumfeld kommt man wirklich noch auf die Idee Stadt sich irgendwie mal Sohn,
zum konferenzsysteme irgendwann vielleicht anzuschaffen und oh Wunder man muss da vielleicht auch Geld investieren über Cayman auf Skype benutzen ich glaube deine Hoffnung wie gut konferenzsysteme sind,
ich weiß dass einer unserer derzeitigen Projektpartner so dumm oder so was heißt das nutzt,
nun heißt es so.
Was soll das ein Software das ist ein Stück was ich glaube ja das muss ich kurz wollt ihr noch mal kurz lustige Wortwitze dann kann ich das reinschreiben.
Schlimm ja na ja sagen wir mal so sie wurden jetzt von von jetzt.
Seinerzeit gekauft und haben dann aber irgendwie,
alles auf die Microsoft Infrastruktur umgestellt ich hatte das auch vor ein paar Wochen da habe ich dann mal wieder Skype aus Gründen benutzen müssen.
Und dann durfte ich durch Sonne durch so einen Prozess durch,
den eigenen User account und Namen wieder zurückzubekommen mit irgend auch irgendwelchen Mails und noch mal hier und noch mal bestätigen und noch mal das und willst du dir nicht noch ein Bildchen geben und willst du Indians es war.
Okay also noch mal kurz um dieses Lumen was ist wirklich eine Konferenz Software und ich komme mir so ein Teil in dafür,
was ist ein echt ganz gut kann es zurzeit mit sehr vielen Personen in diesem in diesem call sitzen kannst video share Screen Sharing machen,
nicht mehr das reicht für vieles schon mal ich weiß nicht was es noch kann und was es kostet so was verstehst du darunter ist es jetzt nur Video Konferenz oder was,
ist das hier in dem Fall war es vor allem wirklich Videokonferenzen mit sehr vielen Teilnehmern plus Screen Sharing,
und recording also für Dokumentationszwecke oder was auch immer wird es halt auch in der Tat aufgezeichnet Anführer Screensharing irgendwelche Software zusätzlich installieren und so,
denkst du denn ich weiß es gar nicht aber ja man muss hoffe installieren und meine leicht ketzerische Frage.
Nee nicht also ja ja.
Okay muss man muss man genau Auto und muss muss mal gucken du hast irgendwie nicht das Gefühl du bist zu blöd die Software zu benutzen.
Wie wird das ich will nicht sagen idiotensicher was ist wirklich tut was es muss und.
Kann man mit leben aber irgendjemand kam auf die Idee wir haben ja nur eine Lizenz lass doch mal über Skype ein Gespräch führen ich das Meer okay Ronny erwähnte ja irgendwann kams,
Microsoft mal auf die Idee das zu kaufen wenn ich kann mich noch sehr gut an das Gespräch mit meiner besten Freundin andere sagt dir nur so wetten das geht jetzt den Berg runter.
Ach ja vielleicht beobachtet bemerkte erst den Berg runter und dann den Bach und dann werde ich bergab bisher an dich schön.
Die Software auch so generell auch so genossen wir haben uns geirrt aber jetzt geht es wieder bergab ich finde es also ein Freund von mir immer so ein so ein so ein netten Freund aus Israel er war,
wirklich ein Philosoph und er meinte ja es geht immer nur.
Backup und ich habe schon wieder am Anfang auch nicht verstanden das begriffen habe so ja warum dagegen die Schwerkraft,
kämpfen so also Backup ist halt schöner und auch ansonsten ich meine bergauf was ist denn da schon zu erwarten darum bist einsam kalt und die Luft ist dünn,
aber ist doch schön hast du keine Menschen die dir auf die Nerven gehen ich bin dann doch lieber in den sonnigen grünen Augen am Fluss,
was Warmes wann waren wir mit Zoom jetzt schon durch Einwurf machen dass mir alles gelungen,
erstmal wann wir denn die tractor irgendjemand kam auf die Idee diesen Skype call zu machen und ich dachte mir so schlimm kann es halt ja nicht sein,
aber dass die da jetzt wirklich so einmal die gefühlten in Telefon screen auf deinen.
Auf deinen Mac zaubern mit allen möglichen blinkenden Sachen und du sitzt davor du denkst das okay ich verstehe die das User-Interface nicht mehr.
Und es kommen die Sachen und ich weiß jetzt nicht ob man etwas wegklicken kann ob es diese Funktionalität gerade überhaupt gibt welche Funktionalität steht mir gerade zur Verfügung.
Also ich habe dieses dieses Stück Software weil das ist noch zu nett ausgedrückt mehr kannst nichts Software nennen.
Schaffe ich bei Skype oder Besprechung bei Skype for business.
Skype weil ich weiß es gibt zwei Skype Teams Team gegeneinander entwickeln bei Microsoft das weiß ich ja weil das die bisherige Video Software von.
Microsoft wurde ja umbenannt in Skype for business cards Design.
Wollt ihr was zum Thema Corporate Halle,
wir haben ja Wunderlist gekauft nur um das Eine zu stampfen und dann ihre eigene To-Do-Liste machen,
also das was mein linkies ist heißt jetzt Skype professional oder Wort von löschen ist oder irgendwie sowas liquacel y.
L-Boxx Elon NC.
Ja das ist sowieso nicht funktioniert relativ gut vor allen Dingen also diese fest eingebauten Lösungen funktionieren relativ.
Abgesehen davon dass es halt manchmal nicht funktioniert,
bitteschön sehr vertrauenserweckend wenn man auf die Homepage geht die URL expandiert zu,
Polycom. Com Flash content Flash Dump Polycom Slash www Slash include,
und die haben.
Nee die haben keinen installierbaren klein sondern du kannst dich über so einen Link dann zu Sonderkonferenz reinklicken und dann musst du aber da halt so eine Browser Extension installieren.
Und ja ich habe auch noch einigermaßen.
Ja stimmt ich habe letztens auch irgendwas genutzt was ohne ohne alles war.
Ja da wir einen kleinen Tipp zwischen Neustadt also kommt er dieses web RTC das kommt ja jetzt ne und wenn ihr einfach mal so eben ganz schnell übers Web Video machen wollten warst das ne das war das genau dann geht ihr einfach auf. In.
Erzeugte einen Rom drücke dir sowieso appear.in Slash Freakshow auch mal machen ich nehme jetzt mal nicht dran teil wenn ihr Lust habt,
okay wie viel Leute daran teilnehmen Konzert ist nur zu zweit benutzen da kann ich jetzt gar nicht sagen ich kriege den,
also das ist wahrscheinlich auch über das ist doch nur eins zu eins oder oder D4 ja und 12 Problem und so weiter na und dass das funktioniert.
Soweit ganz okay so dumm ja so bei ganz viel von diesen also.
Bei meinem vorletzten Projekt da gab es außer diverse Linux User.
Und was vielleicht auf dem Mac oder auf dem Windows dann so mit diesem Video conferencing System ist funktioniert das ist dann noch mal auf Linux wieder eine ganz andere,
nuser delavan,
the best song ever.
Wir sind jetzt in dem indem Freakshow rum sind jetzt vier Leute also außer mir noch drei die haben aber alle Ihre Kamera nicht an.
Skandal Sommer nur zu John bedroom is full upgrade to Proto Alarm more people 4 scheint das Maximum,
sehr gutes durchnummerieren Freakshow 1234 das ist ein Malheur,
ihr könnt euch gegenseitig eure Spielzeuge sein.
Viel Spaß damit.
Ronny ist jetzt abgelenkt für die nächste Stunde nein überhaupt nicht die haben alle ihre Kamera nicht an ich sehe nichts da wo Du gerade hier so dich über die URL lustig gemacht hast.
Also mit Seitenschutz www und so ich hatte letztens auch ein sehr amüsantes Einkaufserlebnis weil ich mir Akustikelemente für meine.
Mein wohnen Schrägstrich Arbeitszimmer mal zugelegt habe Bassfallen im Wesentlichen und ich habe schon öfters mal so bei einem Hersteller geklickt nämlich GEK Akustik,
oder GK Audio hat im Moment ich such dir URL gek.de oder komm ich habe de kriegt,
salzlecker von KTM.
So richtig in Ordnung ist die nie gewesen ja das hat mich auch immer so ein bisschen davon abgehalten da jetzt wirklich zu klicken aber die sind die einzigen die so korrekte Bassfallen und Sodinger bauen zu akzeptablen Preisen.
Und so eine gewisse kannst du mir hierbei kalt auch anbieten und na ja dann hatte ich schon paar mal so diesen Warenkorb gekriegt mit den Bassfallen nicht so haben wollte und dann jedes Mal wieder so abgebrochenen eines Tages kriegt er so drauf und war wieder so kurz davor,
und denke so ne die Preise sind irgendwie es ist viel billiger als sonst dann gucke ich noch mal so.
Jetzt alles okay ich habe es jetzt alles im Warenkorb und da steht pro-modul 141 Euro und dann hab ich mir noch was custom visiert also 170 und dann war aber die Summe,
für 4 Module die 170 € oder sowas Wagner war dann aber nur 422 € inklusive shipping.
Falsche angelegt nee aber da steht doch genau das ne na ich mir neue okay,
wer weiß vielleicht haben sie da gerade irgendwie hat continuous deployment und so heutzutage die Blödmann ja jede Sekunde quasi wenn bei ihm komm mit und seid ist halt mal was reingerutscht ne,
klickst du mal auf Weiter das wird sich ja sicherlich noch korrigieren okay nee der Warenkorb final also jetzt hier,
auch noch schön mit AGB und Terms of Service dieser Kauf ist jetzt binden und so der Preis war immer noch der viel zu günstige Preis ne.
Bei mir okay okay ich kriege jetzt mal und bezahlen wir mit Paypal mal gucken was im PayPal steht.
Mag dich auf Paypal steht auch immer noch der günstige Preis und dann dann in diesem Moment hatte ich mir okay Jungs ich gebe euch.
Bin nett sehr wenn ihr mir jetzt ein Handy in der nächsten Stunde oder in Hessens weißt du eine E-Mail schreibt so sorry sorry sorry,
dann dann lasse ich noch mal mit mir reden soll ich komme ich also ein bisschen entgegen aber im Prinzip war ja mit dem Krieg des Kauf bei uns alles geregelt.
Kann man erst am Abend eine E-Mail auf Französisch von einem sales treu und Google Translate dann wieder Mais kann sich ja lingui noch nicht sagte mir dann also ja so vielen Dank für diese Bestellung und meine Module würden also nächsten Freitag verschickt,
werden sie kam dann noch an alles wie erwartet und zwar am Ende quasi die Hälfte des Preises mittlerweile,
leider haben wir es dann auch g****** also es gab auch keinen Kommentar oder keine E-Mail sofern wegen oder sonst was passiert,
aber in diesem Fall war ich wirklich sehr froh genau diesen Tag erwischt zu haben wo die Webseite so richtig irgendwie aus dem Leim gegangen ist und es wirklich passiert ist und 21 Jahrhundert 2018 jemanden Webshop,
nicht im Griff hat er also.
Du nicht im Griff hat das die Produkte Zahl mit ihrem korrekten Preis drin stehen aber da ist addieren und summieren in einem Warenkorb nicht funktioniert nicht funktioniert und da dachte ich auch so irgendwie an dieses Buch was ich schonmal erwähnt hatte hier people wear.
Wo ja gleich als Einleitung drin steht dass sie dafür so eine consultancy arbeiten und da ihre Lehre noch rausgezogen hätten und,
seitdem sie diese consultancy machen seit 30 40 Jahren,
bauen die Warenwirtschaftssystem ja also entweder fixen die irgendwelche oder bauen sich von scratch und so und es ist nicht so das ist Problem nicht verstanden oder beherrscht wäre ja aber trotzdem.
Welches Produkt hast du da gekauft bei den Bassfallen die mit flexrange Technologie das sind nämlich in membranabsorber.
Also oder heißt es Absorber na ja auf jeden Fall sind das eben nicht Schaumstoff Schaumstoff wäre ich verwechsel das immer.
Also Schaumstoff wandelt ja die Schallenergie quasi in Wärme um richtig durch reiben oder wie.
Die plattenabsorber die haben quasi das ist ein Holzkasten wo,
Holzplatte dann vorne drauf liegt mit Schaumstoff dahinter das heißt die basswellen die regen diese diese Platte an,
die wird durch den Schaumstoff aber in der Schwingung gebremst und wenn die wieder auf zurück geht also ja insgesamt nimmt die einfach die Energie,
aus der Welle mechanisch und nicht also durch.
Abduktion Arsch mit den Begriffen wenn ich jetzt gerade nicht so sattelfest aber genau und damit kann man halt erreichen dass man mit relativ.
Flachen also nicht besonders tiefen Bass fallen trotzdem tiefe Frequenzen dämpfen Kanten,
und das ist auch so ein Prinzip das ist schon relativ bekannt das gibt's auch tatsächlich von der BBC so ein Whitepaper,
sozusagen solche Resonatoren und so zu bauen sind,
ganz cool aber man kann das auch super selber bauen nur ich hatte irgendwie keinen Bock in meiner Küche hat so eine große Holzwerkstatt wieder auf zu Zimmern und mit Stoffbespannung und so weiter und wie gesagt die Preise sind von denen schon einigermaßen fair dafür,
na ja weil das Problem halt so in kleinen Räumen sind eben immer vor allem die Bassfrequenzen.
Weil du kriegst daneben stehende Wellen ich hatte auch schon mal diese eine Webseite wo man so seine stehenden Wellen irgendwie berechnen kann und ich hatte auch letztens erst wir sind Freunde.
Geh mal wieder zum so vorgeführt und er konnte sich das Wort nicht vorstellen habe ich das angemacht meinte hier z.b. mein Raum hat dieses Problem nicht also ja ich höre gar nichts,
ja geh mal einen Meter weiter nach hin und hat sich halt totales was wo man auf den Ohren ahja okay verstehe krass und also dieses Konzept mit stehenden Wellen hat ist ja auch muss man sich auch,
erstmal zu Ohren führen und weil diese basswellen ebenso eine lange Wellenlänge haben,
muss man halt wenn man die so mit Schaumstoff oder so ausbremsen will oder mit wie heißt diese Wolle diese Bau.
Steinwolle ja dann braucht man halt einfach sehr tiefe.
Elemente um überhaupt das sinnvoll absorbieren zu können und deswegen sind dann eben so eine Platten Resonatoren das bessere Mittel nee du wirst wahrscheinlich da absorbieren wo die Welle die stehende Welle ihren Bauch hat.
Weil woanders passiert ja nichts.
Das heißt du müsstest genau an der Stelle eigentlich was mit den mitten in den Raum hängen und das ist ja diese Seite noch mal weil das jetzt wahrscheinlich,
ich kann ja dauern um welche Leute ob ich das noch mal posten Hände weil sie es nicht in die Show notes finden würden also mein Raum,
mit meinen Maßen ist jetzt gerade mal in dieser URL verstecken hat der Mann Anschauungsbeispiel was bei mir so schönes brummt Tim macht dein Sound aus wenn du da jetzt gerade gleich rum Klicks sind gut.
Weil das klingt das unangenehm wenn ihr doch diesen Link kriegt in den Charts am Rock war der Link dann seht jetzt für meinen Raum die Maße und,
bei welchen Frequenzen ich stehende Wellen habe und wenn jetzt da oben rüber fährst mit der Maus über diese Balken,
dann siehst Du halt auch in dem room 3D Darstellung wo sozusagen die,
Berge und Täler sozusagen auftauchen also ne zwischen welchen Wänden oder decken,
diese stehenden Wellen sind und wo du die maximal und minimal hast und dadurch kannst du dann halt auch sehen und du siehst auch noch welchen welche musikalischen Noten oder welchen Noten aus der Tonleiter das entspricht.
Manche Noten sind so schief dass es dich jetzt nicht so ultimativ betrifft aber manche sind halt auch genau,
alle-noten.de zusammenwohnen Sohn so so ein grobes 3D Rendering dieses gesagt des Volumens und manche Tage sind blau manche sind rot und was heißt es wenn es blaues was hast du Brot,
AWO Roth ist sozusagen wenn du maximum hast also die stehende Welle im Bauch dann wieder sagst ja das Blau ist sagen die Null wo du nichts hörst.
Und genau das magst im Moment auch das Mini Moment sich Knoten.
Dann bist Du eben und je höher die Frequenz desto filigrane wird es und desto weniger kritisch ist es meistens auch weil du dann sonst verliert es sich so ein bisschen aber gerade alles so bis 120 Hertz,
also ich sag mal 60 bis 120 Hertz da sind erstens viele musikalische Noten drin,
also Bassfrequenzen einfach unten die sind dann auch relativ grob.
Und massiv also ich hatte bei mir ging es ja so los dass ich da drauf gekommen bin dass ich vorhin Creedence Clearwater Revival fortunate son gehört habe und ich glaube das ist ein f-sharp im Bad mit dem das anfängt so,
dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm ich habe es nicht gehört mir so heißt die Aufnahme kaputt das kann nicht sein wir können jetzt komisch Kopfhörer aufgesetzt nee ist da.
Und dann.
Lernte ich von diesem System sind Helden oder an einer anderen Position im Raum habe ich diesen Song wunderbar gehört und einer anderen Polizei mal den Bass viel zu laut und deswegen.
Ja muss ich bei mir mal zumindest für meine abhörposition ich schicke euch jetzt noch einen anderen Link kurz dazu,
mehr dazu kommt natürlich auch dass die Wellen werden ja vor allen Dingen von Gegenständen absorbiert die halt in der Größenordnung der Wellenlänge sind und dann hast du in den ganzen Höhen ist es irgendwie kein Problem da steht hier eine Pflanze und dann,
was ich denke an Bild an der Wand und so weiter und dann ist es fürs absorbiert schon irgendwie aber aber so ein so eine massives Welle die hat halt auch die Länge,
neuer dass man sich ja deswegen muss man dann eben so andere.
Hast ja keine Litfaßsäule mit einem Raum oder so ich muss jetzt mal hier kurz nach meine Passwörter alle eingeben.
Damit ich euch noch einen anderen total.
Ich suche kurz den Link weil es gibt noch so einen schönen Raum calculator mit dem man auch die Position seiner Boxen halt optimieren kann.
Hier habe ich es auch schon ich habe nämlich gerade so einen Freund geschickt von mir auch noch mal nino www Huneke.
Punkt.de nicht Honecker sondern Huneke und da wenn man da ein bisschen weiter runter scrollt auf der Seite jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen Erklärung dazu.
Ostkreuz Karlshorst.
Sag mir jetzt wiederum seine Raummaße eingeben und auch sagen ob man Teppiche Vorhänge Sessel Stühle und so weiter hat,
und dann kriegt man auch einmal die frequency response von dem Raum gesagt dann kann man auch noch ein paar so Absorber von irgendeinem Hersteller mit angeben aber was dann richtig cool ist,
man kann auch angeben beste Boxen mein Hut.
Dann kann man hier in dieser Grafik wieder links unten ist das nämlich so der Raum von oben und dann kannst du die Boxen da drin rumschieben und auch deine abhörposition und zwar nicht nur.
Sozusagen von oben sondern in der Ansicht da drunter auch in der Höhe weil die Höhe deiner abhörposition ist halt auch entscheiden weil es irgend auf stehende Wellen zwischen Decke und Fußboden gibt,
falls ich kann ja auch mal meine meine Boxen Situation hier in der,
mit der Ebene mal genau die hättest du mal checken ja und dann kann man nämlich relativ gut sehen dass durch Veränderung der abhörposition oder die lautsprecherposition man zumindest die optimale Position im Raum finden kann.
Auch wenn es dann trotzdem immer noch Probleme gibt aber zumindest kann man versuchen,
das Optimum nur alleine durch Position rauszufinden und dann alles weitere mit Bassfallen und Absorbern Diffusoren vielleicht noch zu Bayer,
Ebenau online kann man eben hier auch noch auf dieser Seite sagen ja ich habe jetzt irgendwie solche Absorber von fast Audio die haben halt dann so ein paar Bilder man kann sich das so ein bisschen hin klicken und in etwa.
Zusammenklicken und sehen dass das dann vielleicht was hilft oder nicht aber vor allen Dingen ist eben gut um überhaupt erstmal die optimale Lautsprecher und ab für Position zu finden und gerade bei den Boxen da kann man dann eben nicht nur Standlautsprecher auswählen sondern auch,
2-Wege Kompaktlautsprecher Kik Mainz was drunter noch das Menü.
Dann kannst du nämlich auch noch die Tieftöner Größe und ob das die Öffnung die Bassreflexöffnung vorne oder hinten ist und genau solche Sachen einstellen ist echt ganz cooles,
Tool um erstmal ja grob zu sein Raum,
klangvilla oder sign up für verwirrt ausgeht dass der Raum ist es jetzt auf Deutsch gekriegt einfach ganz neuen angeklickt oben.
Atom Lingen.
Was heißt denn das jetzt hier ich habe das jetzt hier mal so zusammen geklickt hier sieht alles gut aus aber ich kriege überhaupt nicht gut.
Muss die Boxen aber noch ein bisschen in der Höhe das Raum ist verschieben was soll das was ich vorhin gemacht oder soll ich das die geändert habe.
Ja und dann abhörposition muss halt auch dahin gehen wo du ab hörst du sitzt ja nicht an der ganz anderen Wand also auf dem Langenau.
Achso ja und dann siehst Du nämlich was das für euch machen kann je nachdem oder halt sitzt ne und.
Das Einmaleins der Hauptprobleme was so Leute haben Männer im Raum systemanlage aufstellen ist dann dass sie die Boxen an der Leinwand aufstellen,
und das ist halt generell eigentlich eine schlechte Idee also als mit anderen langenwasen Raum ist ja selten quadratisch rechteckig und wenn du es halt in der,
längeren wann zusagen die Boxen positioniert ja dann ist es schlechter in der Regel als wenn du sie an der,
Trennwand funktioniert ja nicht alles richtig das ist schon mal genau super Herrenuhr.
Zimmer für Musik da draußen erster linke Lautsprecher kaputt gegangen deswegen habe ich repariert und jetzt habe ich glaube ich auch kaputt,
ja und die beiden sind genau in der Ecke und du musst halt mal deine Raummaße noch richtig eingeben ist das jetzt ja auch nicht gemacht und irgendeinen Raum und dann siehst Du halt auch an der frequency response da schon mal,
bei diesem Beispiel Raum das so z.b. was ist das da 53 hat oder 63 Hertz was würdest Du gar nichts hören auch interessant na ja also.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall so Web Tools ohne dich um welche große Software zu installieren mit dem man schon mal so ein bisschen gucken kann.
Wie man seinen Klang Vergnügen optimieren kann.
Dann E-Mail.
Also es lohnt sich gelegentlich bei Sensor Webshops auch mal täglich in den Warenkorb zu begutachten und die Moral von der Geschicht die eigene jetzt natürlich dass ich irgendwie nicht gleich irgendwie noch doppelt so viel gekauft habt,
hinterher dann hätte ich ja so richtig Geld gespart aber ja jetzt auch so schon ziemlich gut.
Daten sich dann vielleicht doch noch mal beschwert.
Wo wir gerade bei Audio sind wollte ich noch mal ein Update geben zu dem letzte Woche schon angesprochenen Zoom L12.
Das,
Gerät was letzte Woche noch vor 2 Wochen noch so interessant aussah ich bin nämlich einfach mal gekauft ich habe da noch eine Weile drauf gestanden oder wie ich das ja ich habe was ich am in letzter Zeit selten eigentlich neue Hardware gekauft ist jetzt schon wirklich lange her deswegen war auch mal wieder so ein bisschen an der Zeit und vor allem als ich habe mir das länger durch den Kopf gehen lassen,
und bin dann zum Schluss gekommen das muss ich mal ausprobieren weil eigentlich stimmten alle wollen also stimmt so viele Parameter die,
mir anzeigen dass das Gerät unter Umständen eine neue Qualität.
Darstellen könnte hier in meinem Produktionsprozess ja.
Wau wau wau das will was heißen ja ja sowas sagst du nicht oft nein nein.
Erinnerung das L12 ist eine Art live Mischpult was ziemlich digital daherkommt trotz alledem so eine gewisse Solidität hat 32 digital also,
die ganze Signalverarbeitung ist digital aus dem digital Mixer hat jetzt einen Vergleich zu meinem anderen Digitalmixer keine Motorfehler das auch ein bisschen schade so aber verständlich für diese Preisklasse für das Format und Gewicht,
also es sind halt auch bringen dann auch so eine gewisse Schwungmasse halt mit ne muss nicht.
Finde ich jetzt nichts gehabt hätte wäre also das wäre schon noch mal Upgrade aber ich verstehe schon warum sie das nicht machen weil das ist natürlich ein Luxus den jetzt nicht jeder so bereit ist zu zahlen das hätte das Gerät sicherlich noch mal 200 €,
toll gemacht und schön Teil was jetzt so für 500 irgendwas bei Thomann gerade weggeht na ja,
am 8 Eingangskanäle die auch mit XLR.
Ausgestattet sind mit Phantomspeisung und dann noch mal 2 Stereo Kanäle die,
hätte da 2 Mono Klinken oder zweimal Cinch fressen oder eben,
auch USB und das war schon mal so eine Besonderheit des Gerätes ist die Fahrt halt als Audio Interface 14 Eingangskanäle also eben diese.
8 mikrokanäle plus noch mal die.
Viermal war das denn nur 12 na wo kommt denn die anderen beiden nach Jahres USB oder nee das der die Urlaub B beiden mit dabei über Eingänge.
Da sind ja noch noch vierlein oder.
Bitte anrufen Rene Scheiße L12 was ist 8 Nike Free aber es liefert 14 USB-Ports.
Das ist dann der Master genau also das die 12 Inputs aus den Master und dann hast du aber auch vier Kanäle über USB zu dem Gerät.
Und im Gegensatz zu allem was ich bisher auf dem Markt gesehen habe ist es halt so verschaltet dass wir jetzt wirklich über USB,
in den Standard Mix Abfahrt reinkommt normalerweise diese ganzen USB Dinger bei den billigen Mix hat immer so return Kanäle die nur so zum Abhören gedachten und die nicht selber noch mal auf den eigenen Channelstrip landen,
das hier der Fall was heißt du hast halt diese beiden Stereo Kanäle wahlweise kannst du die analog bedienen oder eben Digital über USB,
sprich du kannst den Rechner halt anschließen OSB und kannst halt alle Kanäle Multitrack aufnehmen Christin Mix noch dazu und,
du kannst aber auch bis zu vier Kanäle,
wieder in diesem Mix mit rein gehen das heißt kannst du theoretisch auch über USB da also eine Feedbackschleife erzeugen das sollte man zwischen den beiden aber es geht das ja schon mal ganz,
ganz okay weil das bedeutet eben dass man da relativ flexibel ist und das bitte natürlich gerade so für zuspielen von,
kam ja einfach die Möglichkeit ne kannst du dann so ein Player Dings haben ist ein Bushaltestelle Verlust gehen wieder in Soundboard Software finden die Lage ist mehr als nur Kanal 1 und 2 abgerechnet.
Das ist ja da nach Jahrzehnten auch immer noch nicht.
Möglich und bitte starte die vier Leuten so ignorant wie solche Software schreiben die Kanal auswählen ja.
Aber nur für die ersten beiden läuft und Apple tut auch nichts egal.
Ich habe jetzt noch nicht so richtig mega viel getestet aber das was ich bisher getestet habe hat mir ganz gut gefallen.
Erstmal sieht Internet Latenz ist okay dann haste meine Kopfhörer aufsetzt.
Mikrofon an Headset anschließen Mikrofon anschließen der Mix gleich wieder in Kopfhörer so das ist so habe es jetzt nicht gemessen aber das,
Suki alles niedrig wird beim Zoom H6 z.b. wenn ich sofort kirre weil da ist irgendwie so eine Grund Latenz drin allein nur durch den internen Mixer,
manchmal noch verschmerzen kann aber die klingt einfach jetzt nicht so wie wie wir das jetzt hier auch gerade so in der Studio Situation haben was einfach auf diese dieses.
Gute reden einfach auch ganz ganz ganz wichtig ist.
Ja und dann hat er letzte Mal schon erwähnt das Ding kann halt Multitrack aufnehmen.
Während es Audio-Interfaces ist auch neu dass das könnte die ganzen anderen sind alle nicht und auch andere Geräte können das,
alle nicht die haben immer so eine entweder oder Nummer da ist so dieses entweder bist du ein Audio Interface oder du bist ein Multitrack Recorder aber warum sollte man beides machen können auf du bist du schon auf dem anderen Gerät auf unsere ganze Musiker Logik die.
Ist jetzt wissen halbwegs ausgeschaltet.
Und dann habe ich auch mal genau dann hat er noch das Ding hat ja Kopfhörerausgänge gleich mit drin 5 Stück das heißt man spart sich halt.
Kopfhörer.
Starker das einfach mal so geil dass es schon immer das Feature was ich gesucht habe kein Gerät auf dem Markt hatte das dass es jetzt das erste Gerät was es hat lebst mit so eigenen Lautstärkeregler für jeden dieser Kopfhörer.
Ausgänge und du kannst dann halt so verschiedene Mixe machen das Problem dass das Ding keine Motorfehler hat haben sie irgendwie.
Na so ganz elegant gelöst du hast halt so,
Prise zu kannst also auch deine Settings speichern und Recall aber dadurch dass sie keine Motorfehler hast bewegen sind endlich die Feder dann halt nicht in die richtige Stelle und das machen sie dann aber eben mit den.
Pegel anzeigen dann eben dass sie eben wenn du ein Recall machst dann für jeden Kanal anzeigen mit der Lampe wo dieser Regler jetzt eigentlich stehen sollte oder wo er jetzt gerade ist und wenn du den Halt,
ändern willst musst du halt den Regler erstmal hin schieben und das sozusagen auflösen und dann kannst Du eben auch den Wert ändern und dann kannst du ihn halt auch wieder,
rehkeulen oder oder abspeichern und ändern und so weiter also ist jetzt.
Also dafür dass keine Motor Fehler drin sind ist das eine ziemlich elegante Lösung oder was man so da haben sie da haben sie wirklich gut drüber nachgedacht,
das muss ich ja das will ich jetzt so im täglichen benutzen dann auch noch mal beweisen und muss ich so ein bisschen dran gewöhnen weil es halt immer so ein bisschen um die Ecke gedacht ist aber ich,
denke mal das ist halt eher so gedacht okay du machst dir da so dein Setup wie sollen die Kopfhörer beschaltet sein wie laut ist.
Also Lautstärke ist aber mal separat also generell welche Kanäle sollen Wowi wie stark reinkommen,
oder speicherst du das halt in irgendeinem setting up und das kannst du irgendwie Colin und dann könnte die Feder irgendwie auch egal sein und dann kannst du das irgendwie so fahren und dann hast du für die life Situation aber immer noch die Möglichkeit mit den Fehlern dann halt auch wirklich so ein Maine Mix auch noch zu beeinflussen und mal jemand lauter leiser zu machen das geht dann halt alles,
da die Frage könnte also wenn der aufnimmt.
Nimmt er dann Postfächer auf und wenn du den als Interface benutzt wird Brief macht er dann trifellner Esprit Fehler auch die Mew Tasse ist hinter dem recording auch die Frequenzeinstellung ist hinter dem recording.de equalizer,
es ist komplett preferida aber kommt Restaurant ist Esprit fehlt aber der Kompressor ist noch davor.
Kompressor 100l ja das macht ja Sinn ne also du willst also alles oberhalb der blauen Leiste.
Also kannst du das Handbuch anschauen da ist ein relativ klareres blockschaltbilder wird ein relativ schnell klar wie das Ding geschaltet ist downloaden also es ist sozusagen dafür gemacht dass dass das eben diese typische Mix Tätigkeit,
ist daneben auch wirklich viel live so,
na und du nimmst halt Multitrack auf hast halt quasi alles aber du kannst halt nicht Minuten oder so du kannst auch während des recordings auch keine Kanäle wieder rausnehmen aus dem recording und so also kann ich sagen jetzt schalte ich mal diesen Recorder wieder an also glaube ich zumindest so war das bei meinen ersten Test jetzt,
okay also wird irgendwie für bestimmte Situation sicherlich manchen auch noch eine Limitierung darstellen aber ich glaube hier ist eine ganze Menge relativ gut gelöst worden und vor allem wofür ist das jetzt gut.
Man stellt sich dieses Teil auf dem Tisch und man braucht dann nur noch Headset anschließen.
Man hat alles was man braucht um guten Podcast aufzunehmen bis zu fünf Teilnehmer theoretisch kann man dann halt noch.
Rossmann hat ja noch drei weitere Mikrofon Anschlüsse also man könnte da halt auch mehr draus machen dann muss man dann doch noch mal,
Kopfhörerverstärker zum kleinen und 4 Porta oder so anschließend die halt alle auf der gleichen auf einem Kanal den dann noch mal verlassen bisschen mehr Formular was geht auch KODi stop.
Ronny begeht gerade den Fehler dass PDF in preview aufzumachen und versuche jetzt gleich das Blockschaltbild zu drehen.
Das in einem anderem PDF viewer gleich den spinning beach ball auf das Netzteil,
ja aber du bist auch gut leiden PDF wollte überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Was habe ich gesagt also man stellt sich das Teil auf den Tisch ist hatte halt ungefähr so die die Größe von Sohn.
Was du schreiben großes Schneidebrett da halt schon so so typische 19 Zoll ja Seite aber nicht DIN A3 mit ein bisschen noch länger.
Ja da hatte ich auch gerade drüber nachgedacht so einen Vergleich anzustellen.
Also stellt euch vor ein Din A3 Blatt wäre so lang wie 19 Zoll Gerät.
Wenn man ein bisschen zieht so das ist das ist gar kein schlechter Vergleich also ein bisschen bisschen.
Bisschen breiter die du hast doch da sein Mittagessen Messinstrument ist nicht lang.
Genau das ist Ina draußen ist der ganz gute ganz guter Vergleich.
Gibt's noch zu sagen also ich muss sagen was mir auch gut gefällt ich habe es jetzt hier nur das erste Mal live gesehen die Buttons und Drehregler als auch die Feder die schnacken und klicken alle sich sehr gut das machen sollen soliden Eindruck finde fancy Lightshow wenn er sich einschaltet,
Schwacke Liste der drehencoder und so das macht alles ein ganz guten Eindruck das fand ich bisweilen bei anderen Zoomen Geräten,
nicht so gut wieder so und Liebe auch.
Gute nicht Motorfader als sorbello Behringer Wackelpeter die dann über die Zeit auch irgendwie ja oder,
nee also das macht auf jeden Fall von der Verarbeitung ganz guten Eindruck wie sind so die Klinke und XLR Buchsen,
mach das auch so Neutrik feeling.
Wie gesagt bin noch nicht zu sehr jetzt zu dir zum Testen gekommen ich habe jetzt auch noch nicht wirklich ein Podcast drauf eingenommen weil ich habe jetzt erst mal getestet einzige.
Das einzige Zwicken im Bauch was ich jetzt am Start hatte war dass das Ding wieder mal nach dem Treiber fragt,
und dass sie das nicht überstanden USB lösen was mich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen verwundert hat weil wir das eigentlich bei Aldi Handy weiß bisher gemacht haben dass er einfach Standard USB.
Audio class machen und die verstehe auch überhaupt nicht warum hier nicht.
Weil du hast jetzt der Treiber macht auch nicht mehr als das ist jetzt nicht dass du da noch irgend so ein control Interface oder sowas hast dafür das ist halt einfach nur die Kanäle rein raus.
Macht allerdings den Eindruck dass die USB,
Latenz relativ geringes also ich habe mal folgendes Setup gemacht da man ja hier quasi 5.
Mischung erstellen kann habe ich.
Kopfhörer nix gemacht wo ich mich dann höre mein Mikrofon und habe aber auf dem.
Master alle Kanäle.
Einfach nur auf USB geschickt aber auch nicht auf den Kopfhörer Mikrofon rein geht durch den Channelstrip landet auf dem USB.
Wir zum Rechner landet aber nicht auf dem Kopfhörer da geht erstmal nur auf USB dann habe ich Ultraschall genommen,
habe die Kanäle alle reinlaufen lassen habe da nichts gemacht und habe,
den Mix dann über USB wieder zurückgeschickt und das Signal auf Kopfhörer eigentlich haben will ja du willst den Mix.
Im Rechner machen weil du dann die Möglichkeit hast ihn sehr viel flexibler zu konfigurieren.
Das funktioniert aber eben nur wenn du so ein klares Focusrite das Teil was ich ja hier bitte melde Dich ja ich habe immer noch nicht wieder bekommen.
Damit hat damit ging dass das genau deshalb habe ich mit dem Focusrite gemacht und es war kein Unterschied,
das ging über Thunderbolt ging das einfach mal so glasklar niedrig latente ich rüber es war einfach ein Traum so genau das Head-Up wollte ich ja eigentlich machen weil ich träume schon lange davon so ein richtigen Software only Setup zu haben.
Weil man dann einfach über MIDI kannst du dann halt Rolf paar Tasten und diesen ganzen Klimbim machen auch mobil was halt hier nicht geht ne,
hier kann ich halt nicht stummschalten weil der Mix ist halt fest und ich will halt eigentlich,
so wie es hier im Schalke Studio habe mit den digitalen Rossmann Tassen arbeiten und dann hilft am eigentlich nur in Setup direkt in in Reaper ein Ultraschall und das muss aber der Mix dann darauf stattfinden,
dafür ist an aber USB doch zu langsam also es ging zwar.
Aber man merkt eben da ist dann Latenz aber sie ist sehr viel geringer als ich es jetzt erwartet hätte.
Inwiefern deiner Treiber dazu beiträgt oder so weiß ich nicht so ganz genau,
man muss natürlich dann bafata ist auch extrem weit runterdrehen also ich glaube ich habe eine Waffe von 32 Bars oder sowas gearbeitet,
1 auch nur mit 48 Kilo hat sich was kann ich kann man das Ding an die auch USB und 192.
5 betreiben ich glaube nicht aber bestimmt die Kanalanzahl runter.
Ich weiß nicht genau was wobei USB 2.0 wieder da die Grenze ist aber das ist ein auch wieder bei Thunderbolts dass er auch kein Thema da geht's halt einfach auch mal hallo sagen das überhaupt tun weil er die poffers Haskala machen kannst.
Dann hat seinen Stil theoretisch ja weil du mir Daten hast.
Dieselbe Anzahl Daten ist repräsentiert dann wird's also du kannst das Ding schick halt schon mal Daten raus das Tempel ist kürzer.
Wenn du das ich sample Puffer hast dann hast du bei einer höheren Abtastfrequenz denke nur einmal pro Sekunde dann weit raus schickst dann muss halt auch eine Sekunde warten irgendwie,
bevor du erreichen, eigentlich klingt es ja so als wolltest du da an lokalen Mix machen und alle Tracks in den Rechner ziehen und dann halt aus den Sachen die du am Rechner hast irgendwie,
ja daran realistisch was man damit machen kann wer wäre da ist in diesem Teil Thunderbolt dran ja das wird aber so schnell nicht passieren ein,
das wird so schnell nicht passieren also den Fall nicht von alleine,
war jetzt drei Jahre egal jetzt ist es an der Wolf Speed rivals wird hatte Thunderbolt nein das ist natürlich.
Das realistische Setup mit diesem Teil ist du schließt A5 Headset an maximal.
Du benutzt die anderen drei Mikrofone entweder garnicht oder für die Sonne LIVE Situation wär das z.b. auch als angenommen macht jetzt hier Podcast auf der Bühne da wir setzen uns irgendwo auf eine Bühne und wollen mit wenig Technik rauskommt vielleicht das Dingen vom Festnetz.
Mikrofone da anschließen die anderen drei Kanäle kannst du z.b. benutzen für ein raummikrofon oder ein höherer Publikum ist Mikrofon so 2.
Mono dynamische Mikrofone irgendwo hinstellt langes Kabel dann hast du die auch noch mit drauf und Christi halt direkt in den Mix mit rein und kannst halt auch definieren wie auf dem Master landen und du hast zwei Stereo zu spielen wenn ich das richtig sehe ne.
Und dann hast du noch zwei Stereo zu Spieler die halt optional eben auch per USB.
Das hat umschalten ob du sie ob die USB nehmen sollen Kanal 12 auf den 1 und Kanal 34 auf den anderen oder analog das heißt du kannst ja jetzt auch noch so eine Ahnung hast auch so ein iPad mit USB.
Dran legen wenn du sonst das nicht als Interface benutzt oder du hast halt keine Ahnung einfach so ein iPod und iPhone mit Klinke output irgendwas halt das analoges oder womit es auch sonst noch anschließen willst.
Oder halt USB über den Rechner kann ich dann noch alle anderen Möglichkeiten mit nutzen steam oder so oder sind sowohl Voice over IP kannst du halt hier auch noch mit einspielen,
ja so bin jetzt z.b. noch Skype damit machen willst kannst du es halt direkt vom Rechner hier rein laufen lassen und dann entsprechende.
-1 Konfigurationen noch fahren also für mich klingt es so nach einem Gerät was die was die meisten Podcaster ziemlich glücklich machen könnte ja das glaube ich auch,
also ich glaube dass das die das Ding ist für mich natürlich nicht aber er mich auch für mich auch ein Problem das Teil also ich muss jetzt erstmal schauen wie ich das mach aber,
im Prinzip auch wenn es viel viel größer ist als ein rh6 ja es klingt besser,
weil der Mixer ist einfach besser es hat halt nicht nur vier Eingänge sondern eben 5 mit headphone amp,
plus noch mal drei das heißt es vielleicht Situation zu gebrauchen in dieser Konstellation die ich gerade beschrieben habe das einfach perfekt und.
Du kannst halt auch noch digital zu spielen was mit riesen riesen Vorteil ist sonst muss ich in meinen Heckmeck machen noch mal mit irgendwie multi-interface und Agrigent die weiße Samen klicken wo ich mir noch mal so ein virtuelles Ding und damit ich mein Soundboard und hast nicht gesehen,
gutes geht in Ultraschall deinem Soundboard jetzt noch anders und was ist dann mit Remote und Wissen Hallo wie alles da rein kriegen,
geht ja auf jeden Fall du kannst das in den Mix reinschicken und die Leute können hören was irgendwie eine Remote Seite macht das kannst Du also auch noch studiolink damit rein,
weben so und hat neun abspiele Kanal so will ich das jetzt mal sagen also benutze USB 12 als Soundboard unbenutzt USB,
3/4 als return Track für studiolink und dann kannst du es halt hier mit dem Mic reingeben oder ist das Ding irgendwie auch komplett ausgelastet,
und es nimmt dann auch noch alle Spuren auf und das auch noch Multitrack so das ist geil und zwar einfach als Backup das einfach weißt.
Es ist egal wer ist gerade Wasser auf meinen Laptop gehst so die Aufnahme bleibt zumindest erhalten.
Außer geht's dir mal Wasser da war ja wieso dann die Effekte die da drin sind sind die brauchbar habe ich nicht gehört effect interessiere mich eigentlich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht also dann das wäre so ein Feature da könnten Sie stattdessen lieber Motorfehler einbauen.
Jan für dich ja so der Kompressor den nassen wahrscheinlich dann auch noch nicht getestet nur der gut so und nicht wirklich nicht was ich auch noch sagen muss also was ich jetzt.
Testen würde wollen hast du mal so einen 250 oben am Körper zum.
Zum Kopfhörer zum Kompressor immerhin ist der Halt regelbar du kannst den anderen sich sehr fein einstellen während du beim H6 kannst inhalt einschalten.
Ja ich habe das auch so oft so eine Schwäche von solchen alle eierlegenden Wollmilchsau Geräten ist es das z.b. der Input gain von den Preamp,
nicht so besonders toll ist oder sie ist früh anfangen zu Rauschen bei dem es glaube ich dadurch relativ große gehen Reserven wenn ich das hier so sehr.
Mit Pad auf 60 dB.
Das klingt jetzt nicht so schlecht dann die andere schlecht ist oft noch dass der headphone Ausgang so ein bisschen schwach Brüste ich ist und damit dann sonst meine 50 Ohm Lautsprecher reinstellt nicht besonders viel Lautstärke rauskriegt das kann ich nicht essen weil ich habe nur 80,
aus Prinzip genau aus dem Grund und wie weit musst du den Regler dafür aufdrehen umso.
Ich habe alles auf Normal gestellt und es war alles vollkommen korrekt laut also wie gesagt hat noch keine.
Keine wirklich habe jetzt erstmal so mehr den Operation Zettel haben Treiberschaltung Mixer Test gemacht und noch nicht so richtig den den den Soundcheck aber ich hatte.
Nicht den Eindruck dass das ein Problem ist ich sage jetzt sieht aus optimal.
Guckt euch das Teil teste das zwei Wochen und wenn es ungeil ist schickt wieder nach Hause,
ja also Thomas in seinen Hause aus welchem Hause auch kam im Hause auch immer kam aber es ist halt.
Vom Preis-Leistungsverhältnis,
es ist ob man kann das Teil Haltern und relativ easy in so einen kleinen Koffer einsperren dann kriegt man sicherlich schnell was praktisches für mich noch nicht mal wundern wenn für das Gerät ist auch schnell so custom cases noch mit auf dem Markt kommen.
Nee es gibt ja 19 Zoll Rahmen ne also.
Da kannst du es ja eben alles was 19 Zoll Karten ist ein 19 Zoll was ich hier überhaupt so Bleche fürs Dach dieses 19 Zoll black den Eiern für den L12 gibt.
Ja okay ich glaube das muss man dann weiter zu schaffen es noch garnicht ja und du kannst ja auch die neuste Firmware installieren falls du es noch nicht gemacht hast die einen potentiellen butcrush verhindert dann keine SD Karte eingelegt ist vor.
104 104 habe ich denn hier.
Was ich halt auch noch als zweiten Anwendungsfall so deswegen nicht darauf aufmerksam,
wann bin und dann als ich hier letzte Woche vor zwei Wochen aber meine Lea eingeführt im oder für Podcast muss auch geil weil ich dachte er ist das ist auch,
supergeil von Proberaum weil,
das Halten live Mixer kannst IP anschließen kannst du deine vocal Mikes oder was auch immer du gerne auf die PLUS kannst dafür nichts machen wenn du so eine Aufnahme Situation so Demoaufnahmen Situation haben willst und die Leute alle Kopfhörer auf haben sollen ja damit irgendwie,
du nicht die PL Benutzer mit nicht den Blüten alle Mikrofone gibt von den Vocals oder was auch immer,
auf dem Proberaum eigentlich eine ziemlich coole Aufnahme Maschine aber hallo fallen das Ding ist nicht so groß genau,
du brauchst halt eben nicht Interface und Computer und noch einen Mixer sondern du hast alles so in einem Ding kannst die Multitrack aufnehmen 8 Kanäle reich natürlich jetzt nicht um einen drum kit Gitarren Bass & vocals alles.
Ebenbürtig zu mikrofonieren aber zumindest man kriegt schon,
relativ gut ne ganze Band sinnvoll abgebildet wie gesagt für Demo Situation allemal und ja gerade auch da sind diese fünf Kopfhörerausgänge ziemlich geil,
Bensheim ja sage ich mal jetzt so ganz grob über einen Kamm geschoren selten mehr als 5 Mitglieder zumindest wenn es sich um klassische Rock Besetzung handelt und da kommt man.
Auch da relativ,
weit unter ihm dann auch unterschiedliche Mixer für die unterschiedlichen Musiker zu haben hier kannst du da tatsächlich unterschied lernen Mixe machen,
du kannst hier okay dir wählen und dann,
und du hast daneben 9 Uhr verschiedene in Presets insgesamt für den globalen state sozusagen das heißt du könntest auch wenn du den Proberaum mit einer anderen Band Hals und die benutzen jetzt auch den Mixer,
leider musste man die Mikrofone noch umstecken im Zweifel da so aber du könntest ihn darstellen für ein oder umstellen da auch vier verschiedene Aufnahmesituationen die sich wiederholen die bis zu neuen Presets abspeichern und das ist auch ganz cool.
Also ich ich kenne er so den Fall dass jede Band ihr eigenes Mischpult Ansteckmikrofon und IPL auch und so,
ja
Also alles in allem okay Tims Eindruck ist gut erster Eindruck ist gut dann werde ich vielleicht auch mal klicken demnächst.
Dicke dicke dicke nee aber für mich ist also ich glaube also für gerade wenn man mit Podcasten anfängt ist es eigentlich nobrainer das Ding also,
Anfänger und 580 € ja nicht unbedingt immer wenn du wenn du jetzt wenn du jetzt,
Kaarster jetzt nicht zu zweit bist sondern eine Runde von vier Leuten hast.
Welche andere Hardware die signifikant billiger ist würdest du denn dann empfehlen ja nie wieder her damit ja auch mal so sehen,
Leute die denken nur in deutlich billiger und dann muss das irgendwie alles insgesamt noch für 200 € zu sein zu haben sein aber wir eh schon so auf der,
Breedlove Gedächtnis Headset weg ist der Button hier noch das passende.
Greta zu bist du jetzt wahrscheinlich noch spannend ob man dieses komische wie ist das Heim c.
Helena das ist es da dran riding aber ich habe mir gerade gestern erst noch mal Ralf Artikel Serie dazu also sind ja mehrere durchgelesen.
Und danach mir so ja okay kann man alles machen ja man kann da die Widerstände einlöten für Phantomspannung und danach Netzbrummen ja kriegt man auch alles irgendwie den Griff aber,
die Zeit ich dann da rein investiert hat und dann noch die Velour Polster damit irgendwie sich an den Ohren auch nicht so.
Also dann bist du auch nicht mehr weit weg von kauf dir doch einfach gleich das richtige und keine Sorgen also.
Ich habe dass mir ich habe auch überlegt so ja wenn ich jetzt zu Hause nicht Podcast aufnehmen würde ich auch mir auch gerne mal weg von den großen Kondensator-Mikrofon die ich ja immernoch benutze die zwar finde ich bei Säuglingen aber,
trotzdem nervig sein weil du halt immer so ein Mikrofon vor der Schnute hast,
und der Visage habe ich eben auch so gesagt der Headset okay kosten immer 140 €,
wie war das noch mal mit diesen 39 € Headsets und danach diesen Artikel also keine Ahnung.
Kann man machen kann man machen nutzen da sehr gute Erfahrung mit haben sich Geld gespart alles super kann man machen muss man aber nicht ja mein Ding ist es auch und ich denke,
der hat ja auch immer an wiederverkaufswerte und Sona relativieren sich solche Sachen.
Aber jeder jeder so viel also willst du trotzdem 12 Lust eine Menge der Probleme die man so hat sie damit aus und ja ein geiles Teil.
Dann.
Aber dieses Thema maximal ausgeschlachtetes wir müssen wirklich mal nicht so lange machen weil ich da noch.
Eigentlich profitieren würde von na dann.
Na dann zwei endlich durchschlafen danach wieder abgeben.
Von Steven Depner heißt der glaube ich mit Namen so schlecht ich Schmerzen bei den Link des Archivs in den Chat.
Ich weiß nicht ich kann es erst ein bisschen lustig die haben eine Serie über Sie aus ich weiss okay ja Business 40 Grad.
Was macht gibst du dir mal weil man kann ja immer aus dem Lernen ne können wir mit dem wie mit der Buchhaltung und fand es einfach spannend so das Thema und war dann ganz,
überraschen sie haben fünf Teile genau das geht los mit Folge 314 what does SEO actually do und ich fand.
Das auch echt lustig diesen diesen Namen den Sie da gewählt haben sie diese Überschrift die sie da gewählt haben und die Leute die sie als IOS haben auch sehr spannend also außer Mark Zuckerberg wo ich irgendwie aus den fünf Folgen.
Ich würde sagen kann gefühlt nur drei Sätze gehört habe alle anderen sind wirklich.
Sie reden sehr viel sie reden sehr offen über ihren ihren Job,
und was ich auch sehr spannend fand natürlich der ganze Park mit uns reden auch wirklich mit Mark Zuckerberg reden wir reden auch mit Mark Zuckerberg aber das ist irgendwie ein Interview nach einem.
Nach einem Facebook event.
Und ich habe das Gefühl dass das wirklich also ich weiß nicht wie lange er sich mit Mark Zuckerberg unterhalten hatte ich glaube er sagte eine Stunde hatte er mit ihm Zeit.
Es ist sehr sehr wenig finde ich in den Podcast gelandet im Vergleich zu,
also wer wirklich sehr prominente ist es in Jalousie die ist die life von PepsiCo Brasilien Edition what does ist CEO explido 314 und geht hoch bis Folge 319,
und Max Ackerbürger kommt immer mal wieder so ein bisschen Feuerwehr ist jetzt nicht so eine prominente Figur wie halt nichts zu sagen oder.
Ich würde sagen will kann ich noch nicht sagen kann ich würde sagen ich habe von dem halt echt nichts mitgenommen paar Sachen die irgendwie spannend sind waren dabei aber,
ich weiß dass ich eine Sache spannend von euch weiß ich nicht mehr weil es war eine von wenigen oder wahrscheinlich was auf die einzige wohingegen halt die Indra nooyi,
super spannend ist so als Person weil sie sehr viel viel viel bitte PepsiCo,
und es ist hier sehr interessant sehr sehr spannend und der andere Typ war glaube ich Jack Welsh der der CEO von General Electric war das jetzt irgendwie um die 80 also Mark Zuckerberg ist der jung,
jüngste mit 33 und er war der älteste mitfahren 80 81 82 glaube ich.
Die heute sehr viel interessante Sachen erzählt und der.
Typ von General Electric hat halt wohl wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe einfach meine Fabrik abgefackelt.
Und wurde halt wirklich zitiert zum zum Chef und gatternweg ein Anschiss sondern ihr eine Analyse warum das passiert ist und warum er das oder wir das beim nächsten Mal anders machen würde und daraufhin,
ist ja wohl bei deiner Elektrik weiter nach oben gestiegen in der leite also auch wie sehr sehr interessanter Gesprächspartner.
Und in einer Folge wäre schon über unser Leitthema Windows kurz und Microsoft kurz gesprochen haben haben sie auch der Insel mit T oder mit d.
Deva.
Entschuldigung Google deine Frage habe ich noch,
genau aber sie haben,
in einer Folge relativ spezifischen sich mit Microsoft beschäftigt und auch mit dem CEO von Microsoft der Satya nadella,
hat er und ich fand die der Weg von Microsoft den sie gegangen sind und wie sie neue Märkte.
Das ist mein Intro high quotes erschlossen hat also ich finde das ist auch ein interessanter Prozess einfach den Sie da beleuchtet haben.
Was würdest du denn sagen das Handy eigentlich jetzt Schusslinie von dem Podcast also worum geht's da.
Geht um Ökonomie ja und da fallen auch so also was ich sehr spannend fand an dieser Reihe war.
Die Debatte muss ein CEO von außerhalb kommen oder von innen aus der Firma heraus also diese Frage fand ich sehr spannend und natürlich halt auch die.
Erkenntnis was halt auf wissenschaftlich und sehr sehr viel in den gesamten Serie Sendungen über die Rolle der Frauen als CEO und wann sie so geholt werden und wann sie als Theo eingesetzt werden und.
Wieder halt auch immer noch teilweise sehr eingefahrenes denken er ist und ich glaub halt dass die Indra nooyi da die.
Eine Figur ist die wirklich sich sehr sehr lange gehalten hat und wahrscheinlich auch.
Eine der wenigen ist die schon lange irgendwo fest im Sattel sitzt da sind wir auch interessant ist so was hältst du verschiedene.
Schwerpunkt Gehalt adressiert warum das ein Problem sein kann und ja also ich weiß nicht ich finde den sehr sehr sehr hörenswert diese gesamte Reihe.
Verschiedene Wege und auch die Frage was macht einen guten CEO aus musst du irgendwie unbedingt alle deine Mitarbeiter kennen oder wie gehst du mit deinen Mitarbeitern so generell um also ich weiß nicht ist halt ein Thema was,
ich gerade eh sehr spannend finde ich mal so ein bisschen mit Business Kram auseinanderzusetzen.
Ganz guter Einstieg finde ich so und halt wie gesagt diese Indra nooyi ist wirklich sehr sehr spannende Personen.
Kann man sich gerne mal anhören wenn man auf sowas steht und dann sonst das der Podcast finde ich eigentlich auch immer mal.
Ein anhören sehr Wert sicher dass sie auch.
So ein paar Extras gemacht haben wo sie unter anderem die kompletten Interviews mit den Netzwerk Netzwerk.
Oje muss jetzt Schluss machen und ähnliche Podcasts Empfehlungen oder so Serien hat nämlich gerne dankend.
Der Empfang Endgegner.
Da ich habe da schon oft von gehört von den Podcast ehrlich gesagt ist ja noch keine Zeit gefunden am Rhein zu tunken,
da viele ja das stimmt und ich habe aber glaube ich auch diesen Brief broadcast weil ich gerade lese mit das early education k way too late also ich habe einige Sachen von denen gehört und.
Das ist sehr sehr spannend wie sie das so beleuchten was sie so viel Gäste haben um Themen zu beleuchten wie lange machen Ihre Sendung.
Sinti sind keine Freakshow so zwischen der 40 Minuten und ich glaube hier das längste ist aber auch ein langes Interview.
Von anderthalb Stunden also 40 Minuten auch nur eine halbe Stunde genau das klassische Podcast Format Netz wieder da.
Was ist denn das in retrato lala und wie war das schon mal besser hin was erlaube Telekom Telekom.
Leute Leute das,
das war's jetzt wir können heute nicht so lange machen ich bin noch durch und muss mich noch um Dinge kümmern und bin schon seit 6 Uhr im Einsatz jetzt mal Schluss bei dir in der nächste Mal mach mal mach mal ein bisschen noch mal ein bisschen.
Mama ein bisschen wehmütiges zurückblicken mal gucken mit was für Fragen oder.
Perlen aus der Vergangenheit einzelne von euch komplett ab dann auch wie ein paar Ideen für ansprechen sollten oder so zu großen was müssen wir da jetzt auch nicht rausmachen aber ist halt so.
Stell uns fragen auf Twitter will ich sagen wir es einfach mal mit dem Hashtag probieren,
dann könnt ihr da alle Folgen und irgendwie sammeln wir das irgendwie einen gucken ob wir das hier in unserem black reingepackt bekommen zum kanal ob das hilft finden fütter insofern ganz gut als dass es eben eine automatische Längenbegrenzung ist es halt die Fragen müssen in einen Tweet passen,
weil der ja mittlerweile,
280 Zeichen ist schon was wegen auch für deutsche Sprache auch ganz angemessen also wir genießen jetzt quasi den Vorteil Indianer vorher schneiden beim Anfahren,
buchstabenbau unter besonderer Berücksichtigung wie sehen Sie im Zusammenhang mit notwendigerweise ja also,
wie gesagt wir beantworten gerne interessante Fragen gerne also gerne.
Oder reden wir haben über interessante Fragen auch nichts Privates aber halt Sommer mal fragen Zusendung oder Fragen zum zum zum zum zum zum Modus.
Oder eben auch einfach konkrete Fragen also was euch sozusagen thematisch grad so auf.
Der silberne gucken wir mal ob er das überhaupt in der Lage sind und dann machen wir es halt einfach nicht immer so oder auch nicht auf dem Tisch Quizfragen.
Schlaf welche Raketen stehen Welt im auf dem Tisch habe ich doch schon erzählt oder nicht ja nein das war eine.
Welche weiteren kommen zu mir immer okay Leute ich glaube wir machen ja einfach mal Schluss voll.
Music.
Weather Live Touchdown.
Moorstuben,
brennende Augen,
ARGE Speyer,
DBV.
Music.
Marie-caroline neuwagenbörse,
Laminatreiniger Seitenteil,
Rigatoni.
Music.
VG sprendlingen-gensingen.
Stehgreif genau,
Megadeth intelligent life somewhere out in space.